I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Everybody, howdy, howdy. We have a really delightful episode today.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0。大家好，大家好。我们今天有一集非常精彩的节目。
Can I say that it's delightful? Is that being braggy? I don't think so. And you know what? I don't care because I'm in my 50s, and when you're in your 50s, you get to give zero f*** and toot your own horn. There you go. Well, to toot toot.
我能说这集很精彩吗？这算是在自吹自擂吗？我不这么觉得。你知道吗？我不在乎，因为我已经五十多岁了，当你到了五十多岁，你就可以完全不在乎别人的看法，尽情自我吹嘘了。就是这样。好吧，自吹自擂吧。
I had a really fun time making this episode. Oh, good. So here's what we're doing today. Our show was inspired by two things. Number one, Michael Scott's Travel Journal from the episode The Deposition in Season 4 and you guys who listen and write in your suggestions. That's right. have gotten so many requests over the years to do an episode of Office Ladies where we read
制作这一集我过得非常开心。哦，太好了。所以我们今天要讲的是这个。我们的节目灵感来源于两件事。第一件事是迈克尔·斯科特的旅行日志，出自第四季的剧集《取证》，第二件事就是你们这些收听并写信提出建议的听众。没错。这些年来，我们收到了无数的请求，希望办一期《办公室女郎》节目，来朗读
from our journals, specifically Angeles journals. Oh my. Let me just read a few. This doesn't even scratch the surface. These are just a few. Amanda from Rhode Island said, hello, office ladies. I have been loving the 6.0 episodes so much. I wonder if you could please, please, please, please, in all caps, have time for an episode of just Angela's journals in all caps. Amanda said, I myself have been journaling since age 12. I am now almost 31 and I'm completely obsessed with Angela's journals. I beg of you in all caps. We need more of this in our lives. Much love Amanda. Amanda, thank you. Yasmin Y from Dallas, Texas said please do an office Lady 6.0 about the journal entries of Angela and Jenna. It can be broken down into categories
我们的日记，尤其是安吉拉的日记。天哪。我只读几封就好。这甚至还只是冰山一角。这些只是一小部分。来自罗德岛的阿曼达说，嗨，办公室女郎。我太喜欢 6.0 版本的节目了。我想知道你们能不能抽出时间，哪怕只有一次，出一期全是大写字母的、专门念安吉拉日记的节目。阿曼达说，我本人从 12 岁起就开始写日记了。我现在快 31 岁了，完全沉迷于安吉拉的日记。我用全大写字母求求你们了。我们的生活中需要更多这样的内容。爱你的阿曼达。阿曼达，谢谢你。来自德克萨斯州达拉斯的亚斯敏·Y 说，请做一期关于安吉拉和珍娜日记内容的办公室女郎 6.0。可以像
like award shows do. We could feature the classics like the bagel or the one where Angela was sick on the plane in first class. Oh Lord. And ones we've never heard of. Fray N from Phoenixville, Pennsylvania said more of Angela's journal please. Jackie Kay from Pittsburgh said, I love an Angela journal entry. Bethany P. from Virginia. said, I would love to hear all journal entries from Angela's journal and Jenna's journal, Lady, there are seriously more requests. Kenna M from Utah, Angie F. from St. Louis, Holly B. from Salt Lake City, said, consider this another vote for Angela's Journal to be one of your upcoming episodes.
颁奖典礼那样分成各种类别。我们可以展示一些经典内容，比如百吉饼事件，或者安吉拉在头等舱飞机上生病的那次。哦天哪。还有我们从未听说过的日记。来自宾夕法尼亚州菲尼克斯维尔的弗雷·N 说，请多分享一点安吉拉的日记。来自匹兹堡的杰基·K 说，我太喜欢安吉拉的日记内容了。来自弗吉尼亚州的贝瑟尼·P 说，我好想听听安吉拉日记和珍娜日记里的所有内容呀，天哪，请求真的还有很多。来自犹他州的肯娜·M、来自圣路易斯的安吉·F、来自盐湖城的霍莉·B 都说，请把这算作又一票，让安吉拉的日记成为你们接下来的节目主题之一吧。
Oh, man, no pressure. I mean, I don't even know how many I just read, but there were dozens. Thank you, everybody. So everyone, a few weeks ago, we were talking about some family trips we had coming up for spring break. And I said, and why don't we journal about our travels and then share them on the pod. And you guys know how much I love a travel journal. So we did just that. We both journaled about our travels.
天哪，压力山大啊。我是说，我都不知道刚才读了多少条，反正足足有几十条。谢谢大家。所以各位，几周前我们在聊即将到来的春假家庭旅行，然后我说，为什么我们不把旅行记录下来，然后在播客里分享呢？你们知道我有多喜欢旅行日志。所以我们就这么做了。我们俩都把各自的旅行写成了日记。
We're going to share them with you today. But before we get to our journals, we also wanted to share with you about the new format for our show. Yes. I know some of you have been wondering what exactly our show is now that we're done with the official, the office rewatch chapter of the podcast. And well, so were we. Yeah. You may have noticed. We've been trying a few different things, but we think we figured it out. Yes. So over the past few months, we've been tinkering and we decided to create a new structure using some of our favorite things. There are things that you've told us you love. So here's how we're going to structure our Wednesday 6.0 episodes. We're going to start with a chit-chat. We've already been doing this.
我们今天就要和大家分享。不过在我们分享日记之前，我们还想和大家聊聊我们节目的新形式。是的。我知道你们有些人一直在好奇，既然我们已经结束了官方《办公室》重温这部分的播客，那我们的节目现在到底是什么样的。好吧，其实我们也很想知道。是的。你们可能注意到了。我们一直在尝试一些不同的东西，但我们觉得我们已经找到了方向。是的。所以在过去的几个月里，我们一直在摸索，并决定用我们最喜欢的一些东西来构建一个新的结构。这些都是你们告诉过我们你们喜欢的东西。所以我们周三 6.0 版本的节目结构将是这样的：我们首先会进行闲聊。我们一直在这么做。
We love it. Love it. We get our suggestions from you and we love them. And then at the end of each episode, we are going to feature Around the Town and an office question of the week. And the Around the Towns are going to be a mix, you guys, of the digital messages you send in, plus some of the old-fashioned post office mail we get. And then, of course, our office question of the week is our chance to answer any office-related questions you might still have for us. So now that brings us to the middle.
我们很喜欢。非常喜欢。我们的建议都来自你们，我们爱死这些建议了。然后在每一集的最后，我们将推出“走遍小镇”和“本周办公室问题”环节。“走遍小镇”将会是一个大杂烩，各位，里面既有你们发来的数字信息，也有我们收到的老式邮政信件。然后，当然了，我们的“本周办公室问题”环节则是我们回答你们可能对我们仍有的任何与《办公室》相关的问题的机会。好了，现在这就把我们带到了中间环节。
Yeah, what is the middle? The meat, the protein. The middle of the episodes are going to be a mix of different things, like interviews with office cast and crew, writers, directors, or maybe even famous fans of the office. We've got one of those coming up. Or sometimes just someone we find inspiring. We might invite someone to play two truths in a lie. Maybe we'll do a deep dive into something that interests us
对，中间环节是什么？干货，核心内容。节目的中间部分将由各种不同的内容组成，比如对《办公室》演员和幕后工作人员、编剧、导演的采访，或者甚至是《办公室》的知名粉丝。我们接下来就会有一期这样的采访。或者有时只是找一个我们觉得鼓舞人心的人。我们可能会邀请某人来玩“两真一假”的游戏。也许我们会深入探讨某个让我们感兴趣的事物，
or explore a fan theory about a moment from the office. Basically, the middle of the episode is our chance to mix it up. It's our chance to have fun and be creative. Exactly. And we're still planning to do more of our All About the Office character episodes. And also we love a good movie breakdown, y'all. So we're going to do those a few times a year, too. And we especially love getting suggestions for episodes from you guys.
或者探讨粉丝对《办公室》某个时刻的理论。基本上，节目的中间部分就是我们推陈出新的机会。这是我们找乐子、发挥创造力的机会。没错。而且我们依然计划制作更多关于《办公室》角色的“走遍角色”节目。另外，大家知道我们很喜欢深度解析电影。所以我们一年也会做几次这样的节目。我们尤其喜欢听取你们大家对节目主题的建议。
So please write to us. I know I've said it a gazillion times, but one of the things we cherish the most about office ladies, truly is this amazing community. You guys, we love you. We do. We love this community and we love working together. So we hope you will stick with us as we move into featuring episodes that might be more office adjacent than office center. entered like today. This episode today is inspired by something you've told us you want to hear more of Angela's journals. And listen, for those of you who just want straight up the office, you're just
所以请给我们写信。我知道我已经说过无数次了，但《办公室女郎》最让我们珍视的东西之一，真的是这个了不起的社区。大家伙儿，我们爱你们。真的。我们爱这个社区，我们也热爱一起工作。所以我们希望，当我们转向推出那些可能更接近《办公室》外围、而不是像今天这样以《办公室》为核心的节目时，你们能继续支持我们。今天的这期节目灵感就来自于你们告诉我们的心愿：想听到更多安吉拉的日记。听着，对于那些只想看纯粹的《办公室》内容、觉得
like, ladies, I just want to hear about the office. Our whole entire rewatch library will always be there for you. It's on every Monday. We are going in order. All of the seasons will be featured and our Monday's second drinks. And you know, second drinks means that's new fun stuff at the top. All right, so let's get started with this episode. We are starting with our chit-chat suggestion. Here it is. It's from Alex S from Canada, who said, Hi, ladies, I love your podcast. I think you should discuss your journals for a chit-chat.
“女士们，我只想听关于《办公室》的内容”的听众朋友们，我们整个重温库将永远为你们敞开。它每周一都会更新。我们会按顺序推进。所有季都会涵盖，还有我们周一的“第二杯饮品”环节。而且你们知道，“第二杯饮品”意味着开头会有新的有趣内容。好了，那我们就从这期节目开始吧。我们从我们的闲聊建议开始。内容是这样的。来自加拿大的亚克斯·S 说，嗨，女士们，我太喜欢你们的播客了。我觉得你们应该在闲聊环节讨论一下你们的日记。
I'd love to know everything about your journaling style. Do you use stickers or stencils? Have you ever tried bullet journaling or junk journaling? Where do you store them? Where do you store your supplies? Do you have a special pen you like? as a lover of the office and your podcast, I was delighted to find you ladies also love to journal. I love when you read your journal entries as well. Maybe you could do a deep dive on journaling.
我很想知道你们写日记风格的一切。你们会用贴纸或模板吗？你们试过子弹日记或垃圾日记吗？你们把它们存在哪里？你们把日记文具存放在哪里？你们有特别喜欢的笔吗？作为《办公室》和你们播客的爱好者，我很高兴地发现你们女士们也喜欢写日记。我也很喜欢听你们读日记内容。也许你们可以深入探讨一下写日记这件事。
Thanks so much, ladies. Lots of love from Canada. Oh, Alex. I love this question. One, I love that it aligns with our episode today because you know I love that. That was a great find. It was. But also, I do have very specific journal habits. Do you, Angela? Well, you might be surprised or not surprised. I don't have any specific journal habits. I'm pretty free form. I guess if you could say anything, I'm sort of observational, you know? Sure.
非常感谢，女士们。来自加拿大的满满爱意。哦，亚历克斯。我太喜欢这个问题了。第一，我喜欢它和我们今天的节目主题不谋而合，因为你知道我有多喜欢这一点。这是一个极好的发现。确实是。不过话说回来，我确实有非常具体的写日记习惯。安吉拉，你有吗？嗯，你可能会感到惊讶，也可能不会。我没有什么特别的写日记习惯。我挺随性的。如果要说有什么的话，我大概是属于观察型的吧？当然。
You have a point of view. Yes. Yes. But what about you, Jenna, if you have these specific habits, what are they? Well, first of all, yes, Alex, I have a specific pen I like to use. Or a specific type of pen. I like roller ball ink pens. Okay.
你有自己的视角。没错。没错。那珍娜你呢？如果你有这些特定的习惯，它们是什么？好吧，首先，是的，亚历克斯，我有一支喜欢用的特定笔。或者说特定类型的笔。我喜欢滚珠墨水笔。好吧。
And I get grumpy when I have to journal with any other pen. Okay. I will say I don't like to journal with any pen that smudges and then gets on my hand. Same. Okay. I also have multiple journals and they have categories. Ooh. So some of them I write in with pen and some are typed.
如果必须用其他任何笔写日记，我就会变得暴躁。好吧。我得说，我讨厌用任何会弄脏然后蹭到手上的笔写日记。我也是。好吧。我还有好几个日记本，它们是分类的。哦。所以其中一些我用笔写，另一些则是打字输入的。
I'll explain. First of all, I have a creative journal. This is where I write down quotes from books that I feel like might inspire. me in the future if I'm working on a creative project, like maybe for a character I'm playing or something. Oh, that's so you, and I just love it. But I'll also have an observation, and it'll go in my creative journal. Like this morning, I set my to-go coffee on the hood of my car. And then when I got in my car, I had to open my door and get it because I'd forgotten it. And it was a little too far for me to reach, but I could reach it. Did you spill it? No, I didn't spill it. But I was,
我来解释一下。首先，我有创意日记。这是我用来记录书中名言的地方，如果我在进行创意项目时，比如为我扮演的角色或其他事情做准备，我觉得这些名言将来可能会给我启发。哦，这太符合你的风格了，我简直爱死这个了。不过我也会有观察记录，它会被写进我的创意日记里。就像今天早上，我把我的外带咖啡放在了车引擎盖上。然后我上车后，不得不打开车门去拿它，因为我给忘了。而且对我来说稍微有点远够不着，不过我还是够到了。你洒出来了吗？不，我没有洒出来。但我当时想的是，
what I thought was, oh my God, if I ever have to play a character who puts her coffee on her hood, I should put it a little too far because it's more realistic that you have to reach for it. I'm going to make a note of that. I'll put that in my creative journal and I'll unpack that sometimes. So if you ever see me in a movie reaching for a coffee on the hood of my car, you'll know where it came from. This is very much like sort of the artist in you. Oh my goodness.
哦天哪，如果我以后要演一个把咖啡放在车引擎盖上的角色，我应该把它放得稍微再远一点，因为这样你得费劲去够它，会更真实。我要把这个记下来。我会把它放进我的创意日记里，以后有时会把它展开发挥。所以如果以后你在某部电影里看到我伸手去拿车引擎盖上的咖啡，你就会知道灵感是从哪来的了。这非常有那种你身上的艺术家气质。哦天哪。
Well, anyway, so that's a pen and paper journal. I also have a personal journal. That's where I try to process like life stuff. That's also pen and paper. For that journal, I love a prompt. There's a lot that you can find on the internet. So sometimes I'll look up a prompt and I'll use that for my personal journal. But I also have a journal for each of my kids. And I keep those on my computer. And I go to it from time to time and I just write about them. It's something that I want to give them when they're older. And I'm really glad I did this because when I scroll back to an entry from when they were like, we little,
好吧，不管怎样，这是纸笔日记。我还有一个个人日记。那是我用来试图处理生活中各种事情的地方。那也是纸笔日记。对于那个日记，我喜欢有提示。网上能找到很多这样的提示。所以有时我会查找一个提示，然后把它用在我的个人日记里。不过我为每个孩子也都准备了一个日记本。我把它们存在我的电脑里。我时不时会打开它，写一些关于他们的事。这是我想在他们长大后送给他们的礼物。我真的很高兴我这么做了，因为当我翻看他们还很小、像小不点儿时的日记时，
I will have recorded some funny phrase they said, or like the name of their treasured stuffed animal at the time. And it's stuff that you think you will never forget, but I had actually forgotten. You do, though. You do. You forget. Yes.
我会记录下他们说过的一些滑稽短语，或者当时他们最珍爱的毛绒玩具的名字。这些都是你以为你永远不会忘记的事情，但我其实已经忘光了。不过确实如此。你会忘记的。是的。
And I so wish that I had written even more. But I'm grateful that I did it at all. And I'm always backing it up and printing it out and making sure that it doesn't get lost. You know, that's like my one anxiety about that journal. But then I also have a separate travel journal, which is also on my computer. And I love making photo albums of our travels. And then I include the travel journal in the photo album.
我真希望我当时能写得更多。但我很庆幸我还是写了。而且我一直在备份、打印，确保它不会丢失。你知道，这是我关于那个日记的唯一的焦虑。不过我还有一个单独的旅行日记，这也是在电脑上的。我喜欢制作我们旅行的照片相册。然后我把旅行日志也放进照片相册里。
So, yes, I have a lot of journals and a lot of habits and organization for my journals, Alex. Well, I guess I wasn't really thinking about some of the other things that I sort of document. But I had a journal given to me as a gift. This is a great gift, by the way, if you have a friend or family member who's having a baby. I was given a journal, and it was like quote of the day from your kids. Oh yeah, one line a day journal? Yes. Yes. And I went in and wrote all these fun things and I still have that. And Isabel and I just love it. We go back through it from time to time. And then actually, I did this thing, lady, because you know I have all my digital clutter. I would send a weekly update to my mom and dad about what Isabel was up to with a little
所以，是的，我有许多日记本，关于日记我也有很多习惯和整理方法，亚历克斯。嗯，我猜我以前没怎么想过我记录的其他一些事情。不过我曾收到过一本别人送的日记本作为礼物。顺便说一句，如果你有朋友或家人正在生宝宝，这是一个极好的礼物。我收到了一本育儿日记，里面记录的是孩子们的每日金句之类的内容。哦，对，一天一行的日记？对。是的。我曾进去写了所有这些有趣的事情，我到现在还留着它。伊莎贝尔和我都很喜欢它。我们时不时会翻看它。然后实际上，女士，我做过这样一件事，因为你知道我有各种数字杂物。我会每周向我爸妈发送更新，讲讲伊莎贝尔最近在做什么，并附上一张小小的
picture. So I went and I compiled all of those emails. And I have them like on a folder. on my laptop. That is all these snapshots of her life. That is such a great idea. I want to go through my digital clutter. I'm not as good at keeping digital clutter as you. I bet I could pull some even more stories to add to it. Yeah. And what was really special for me is, you know, since my dad has passed, were his responses. Sure. You know? Yeah. So that's really special. And, you know, when I was younger, when I was single, like college age and in my 20s, I would keep a journal on my nightsteen. And like I had a top drawer, you know, like on my nightstand. And I would write in it in the evening.
照片。所以我去把所有这些电子邮件都整理到了一起。我把它们放在我笔记本电脑上的一个文件夹里。全都是她生活的快照。这真是一个绝妙的主意。我也想去清理一下我的数字杂物。我在保留数字杂物方面不如你擅长。我敢打赌，我还能找出更多故事加进去呢。对啊。而且对我来说特别珍贵的是，你知道的，自从我爸爸去世后，就是他给我的回复。当然。你知道吗？嗯。所以那真的很特别。而且，你知道，自我年轻的时候，自我单身时，比如大学时代和二十多岁的时候，我会在床头柜上放一本日志。就像我床头柜上有个抽屉，你知道的。我会在晚上在里面写字。
It would be kind of part of like just a little bit about my day. And I haven't done that for years. Well, you know why I bet. I think that's what phones have robbed us of. Oh, right. Because I used to do that too. And now I like scroll. Scroll.
那差不多算是我一天生活的一点记录。我已经好几年没这么做过了。好吧，你知道我打赌这是为什么吗。我觉得这就是手机从我们这里偷走的东西。哦，对。因为我以前也这么做过。而现在我只会刷手机。刷手机。
See what's happening today. Because I don't check my phone throughout the day. But at night, sometimes I'm like, well, what happened today? Exactly. Yeah. You're so right. Well, you know, Alex, I also loved your chit-chat suggestion because it got me curious. I didn't know what junk journaling was.
看看今天发生了什么。因为我白天不怎么看手机。但到了晚上，有时我会想，嗯，今天发生了什么？完全正确。是的。你太对了。好吧，你知道吗，亚历克斯，我也很喜欢你的闲聊建议，因为它勾起了我的好奇心。我以前都不知道什么是垃圾日记。
I'd never heard the term. And I guess it's a type of journal one that you craft from recycled, found, or discarded materials. So it looks like this old book in a way. And then I found this amazing, wonderful website called Artjournalist.com. It's made me want to journal even more. I mean, the person that created it gives you prompts, lady. There's prompts for so many different types of journaling, art journaling, photo journaling. And we both do scrapbooks.
我以前从来没听过这个词。我想这是一种由回收的、找到的或废弃的材料手工制作的日记。所以从某种程度上说，它看起来就像一本旧书。然后我发现了一个神奇美妙的网站，叫作 Artjournalist.com。它让我更想写日记了。我是说，创建这个网站的人会给你提供提示，女士。有针对各种不同类型日记的提示，艺术日记、照片日记。我们俩都做剪贴簿。
So I do think that's a type of photo journaling. A hundred percent. But then they have prompts for holidays, lady. Like Thanksgiving are one-word prompts. And she has a whole section for prompts for travel journaling. Well, Angela, Yasmin suggested that we revisit this journal idea with different prompts. We totally could. Well, let's see how today goes.
所以我认为那确实是一种照片日记。百分之百。但他们还有关于节日的提示，女士。比如感恩节或一词提示。她甚至还有一整节专门关于旅行日志提示的内容。好吧，安吉拉，亚斯敏建议我们用不同的提示重新审视这个日记的想法。我们完全可以这么做。好吧，让我们看看今天进展如何吧。
All right. Well, I love any excuse to start a new journal. And one other thing, dare I say, I think this podcast is a kind of journal. Especially as we did the rewatch. It's an oral journal. Yes. Of our memories. Or as you say, sometimes we journal out loud to one another.
好的。好吧，我喜欢任何可以开始写新日记的借口。还有一件事，我敢说，我觉得这个播客本身就是一种日记。尤其是当我们重温剧集的时候。这是一本口述日记。是的。记录着我们的记忆。或者就像你说的，有时我们会大声向彼此倾诉我们的日记。
I do. We find things. We process things through our messages to one another. Yeah. All right. Well, listen, everyone, why don't we take a break? And then it is time for us to share our travel journals. And I think we'll have to hear Michael Scott's journal, too.
我是这样。我们发现问题。我们通过发给彼此的信息来处理事情。对啊。好吧。听着，各位，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后就到了我们分享旅行日志的时候了。我想我们还得听听迈克尔·斯科特的日记。
Oh, it's the best. What of everything you learned in history class was only half the story? I'm Dr. Hrini-Bot, host of Hidden History. Every Monday, I go where history gets mysterious. Vanished civilizations, doomsday prophecies, paranormal phenomena, and events that science still can't fully explain. On Hidden History, I treat these moments like open case files, not miss, not superstition, just incomplete explanations waiting for closer
哦，这太棒了。如果历史课上学到的一切都只是真相的一半呢？我是《隐藏历史》的主持人赫里尼·博特博士。每周一，我都会探寻历史变得神秘莫测的地方。消逝的文明、世界末日的预言、超自然现象，以及科学至今仍无法完全解释的事件。在《隐藏历史》中，我把这些时刻当作未结案件档案来对待，而不是神话，不是迷信，只是在等待更近距离观察的
look. Listen to and follow Hidden History, available now wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back. And before we dive into our travel journals, it is time for Michael's. It's from the deposition, you guys, it's just one of our favorite moments. Jan's lawyer is going to read from Michael Scott's Journal. Let's hear it. We'd like to enter into the record a page from Michael Scott's personal journal. Whoa, whoa, whoa, what are you doing with my diary? This is plaintiff's Exhibit 107. I quote from an entry dated January 4 of this past year. Just got back from Jamaica.
不完整解释。收听并订阅《隐藏历史》，现在各大播客平台均可收听。好了，我们回来了。在我们深入探讨我们的旅行日志之前，是时候听听迈克尔的日记了。出自《取证》那集，各位，这绝对是我们最喜欢的时刻之一。简的律师将朗读迈克尔·斯科特的日记。我们来听听。我们希望将迈克尔·斯科特个人日记中的一页作为证据记录在案。哇，哇，哇，你在对我的日记做什么？这是原告第 107 号证据。我引用一段日期为去年 1 月 4 日的日记。刚从牙买加回来。
Tan almost everywhere. Jan almost everywhere. He-he. Oh, Diary, what a week. I had sex with my boss. I don't know if it's going to go anywhere. Jan was very specific that this is not going anywhere, that it was a one-time mistake.
几乎到处都晒黑了。几乎到处都是简。呵呵。哦，日记，多么棒的一周。我和我的老板发生关系了。我不知道这会不会有什么发展。简说得很明确，这不会有什么发展，这只是一次性的错误。
But we had sex six times, so you tell me. I am definitely feeling very eerie. IRI. Irie. Sorry. More tomorrow. X-O-X-O. Michael.
但我们做了六次，所以你们评评看。我绝对感觉非常美妙。美妙。抱歉。明天继续。亲亲抱抱。迈克尔。
Amazing. It's so good. It just makes me laugh because I talk to my journal the same way. I know you do. And I did it before Michael Scott did it, you guys. All right. Is this the time where we share our travel journals? I think so.
太棒了。太棒了。这简直让我笑出来，因为我和我的日记说话也是这样。我知道你也是。而且我比迈克尔·斯科特更早这么做，伙计们。好了。现在是时候分享我们的旅行日记了吗？我想是的。
And lady, I believe you should go first because you're the one that everyone wants to hear. Oh, gosh. Okay. no pressure. Well, you guys, it's nothing special. It's just me traveling. Okay? All right. Okay. This is just... Sam and I are so excited right now. And Matt, this is going to be your first time hearing an Angela Travel Journal. I'm excited for you. I can't wait. I feel such pressure. Here we go. Okay. I titled it Travel Journal. It's a good title for it. Oh, wait. First, you guys, I want to just share with you that my My trip was multiple flights as we did college tours.
而且，亲爱的，我认为你应该先来，因为你是大家都想听的人。哦，天哪。好吧。没有压力。好吧，伙计们，这没什么特别的。这只是我的旅行。好吗？好吧。好吧。这只是……萨姆和我都快激动死了。马特，这是你第一次听到安吉拉的旅行日记。我为你感到兴奋。我等不及了。我感到了好大的压力。我们开始吧。好吧。我给它取名为《旅行日记》。这是一个很好的名字。哦，等等。首先，伙计们，我想和大家分享的是，我的旅行有多个航班，因为我们在进行大学参观。
Okay? Yes. So multiple destinations over spring break, but it started with me going to Texas to see my family. All right? So I just feel like you need to know what my trip was. And here we go. Monday, March 23rd, 237 p.m. That was, first of all, I just love that I know what time it is.
好吗？是的。所以在春假期间有多个目的地，但它是从我去德克萨斯州看望家人开始的。好吧？所以我只是觉得你们需要知道我的旅行是什么。我们开始吧。3月23日，星期一，下午2点37分。首先，我只是喜欢我知道现在几点了。
I love it so much that you put the time every time. LAX to Dallas Fort Worth, American Airlines. These are book reports. This is how these start. Here we go. It's been a while since I've journaled on a plane. But Jenna suggested we do travel journals since we are both taking trips over spring break. Old Me would explain to you that I do a rewatch podcast called Office Ladies with my BFF, Jenna.
我太喜欢你每次都写上时间了。洛杉矶飞往达拉斯沃斯堡，美国航空公司。这些是读书报告。这就是这些开头的形式。我们开始吧。距离我在飞机上写日记已经有一段时间了。但珍娜建议我们写旅行日记，因为我们两个都要在春假期间去旅行。以前的我可能会向你解释，我和我的好闺蜜珍娜一起做一个叫《办公室淑女》的重温播客。
Jenna Fisher. We're on a TV show together called The Office. Okay. So I'm heading to Texas to see my mom and sisters. I'm traveling alone, and then I'll meet up with Josh and the kids in Colorado to start some college tours. I like to take a few trips a year to see my mom by myself. I love having that one-on-one time with her, separate from big family gatherings and holidays,
珍娜·费舍尔。我们一起出演了一部电视剧叫《办公室》。好。所以我要去德克萨斯州看望我妈妈和姐姐们。我独自旅行，然后我会在科罗拉多州与乔希和孩子们会合，开始一些大学参观。我喜欢一年去几次看望我妈妈，就我一个人。我喜欢和她单独相处的那段时光，与大家庭聚会和节日分开，
et cetera. You get it. Your journal is like, I gotcha. Yeah, we got it. Okay. I think travel journaling is my favorite type of journaling. Maybe because at home, I get lost in chores and school activities and work, and it's hard to find time to just sit and be
等等。你懂的。你的日记就像是，我懂的。是的，我们懂的。好的。我认为旅行日记是我最喜欢的日记类型。也许是因为在家里的时侯，我迷失在琐事、学校活动和工作中，很难找到时间去坐下来，静静地
still and write. But maybe also it's because I love travel and being a spectator to new places and people. I love people watching. I also love just people. I love meeting new people, talking to new people. I find people fascinating. So here it goes. Dot, dot, dot.
写字。但也许也是因为我热爱旅行，喜欢作为一个新地方和新人们的旁观者。我喜欢观察人。我也单纯地喜欢人。我喜欢结识新的人，和新的人说话。我觉得人很有吸引力。所以就这样了。点，点，点。
The couple next to me have on matching t-shirts. Her says Bell. His says Beast. Do we think they went on vacation to Disneyland and are now flying home? I think, yes, exclamation point, took a nap at take off. I have a meal update. I got the pita chips and what I thought was hummus. Was not hummus. No idea what it is, but I'm eating it. Maybe some type of cream cheese dip. Bought a full flight Wi-Fi for $19. Then it went out, exclamation point. Pilot came on and said the satellite they used for
我旁边的那对夫妇穿着情侣T恤。她的上面写着“贝尔”。他的上面写着“野兽”。我们觉得他们是去迪士尼乐园度假，现在正坐飞机回家吗？我想，是的，感叹号，起飞时小睡了一会儿。我有一个餐饮更新。我拿了皮塔饼干和我认为是鹰嘴豆泥的东西。不是鹰嘴豆泥。不知道那是什么，但我正在吃。可能是某种奶油奶酪蘸酱。花19美元买了一整趟飞机的Wi-Fi。然后它断网了，感叹号。飞行员广播说，他们用于
Wi-Fi had switched its orbit, W-T-F. He said it takes a while to resell. set to the new orbit. Mm, okay. Are we going to have time for like the rest of the, we're still on the place? Yeah, I know. That's what I mean. I'll speed it up, guys. No, don't.
Wi-Fi的卫星改变了轨道，妈的。他说重新连接并设置到新轨道需要一段时间。嗯，好吧。我们会有时间做比如剩下的，我们还在飞机上吗？是的，我知道。这就是我的意思。我把它加速，伙计们。不，别。
Okay, don't. Okay, don't you skip it out. There is free entertainment. Just pick the movie Divergent. Oh my God, I want to break this down on the podcast. I have so many questions and need to discuss. Also, the man next to me seems nice, but he isn't chatty. He ordered a Heineken.
好吧，别。好吧，别跳过。这里有免费娱乐。就选电影《分歧者》吧。哦，天哪，我想在播客里剖析这部电影。我有太多的问题需要讨论。还有，我旁边的那位男士看起来人不错，但他不爱聊天。他点了一瓶喜力。
He's sleeping now. He got some cheese plates. It looked good. I wish I could have had some. He did not get the mystery dip. Friday, March 27th, 245 p.m. Dallas to Los Angeles, American Airlines, Flight 1744. Wait, we're already on another plane. You guys, I just traveled. So all my entries are from the airport. Should I have said that? Yes. Sorry. I just went from flight to flight. Okay. I'm going to talk about my trip on the next entry.
他现在在睡觉。他拿了一些奶酪拼盘。看起来不错。我真希望能吃一点。他没有拿神秘蘸酱。3月27日，星期五，下午2点45分。达拉斯飞往洛杉矶，美国航空公司，1744号航班。等等，我们已经在另一架飞机上了。伙计们，我刚刚在旅行。所以我所有的记录都来自机场。我本该这么说吗？是的。对不起。我只是从一个航班飞到另一个航班。好吧。我将在下一条记录里谈谈我的旅行。
Okay. So where you journal is the airplanes. Our airport. Got it. Do you speak about more things than the planes? Okay, good. Ready? I had such a great visit with my mom. Each evening I was home, we sat on the front porch with my sisters and my niece and her new little baby girl, and we watched the sunset and just visited. One day, mom and I went driving around our little town of 1,800 people, and she just pointed out different things, like who got a new carport, or who's moved, or how this young couple from church is looking to buy their first house, and maybe the fixer up or by the elementary school. or what's happening at the feed store and who's building out by the dairy queen. You know, stuff like that. I hung on her every word. I loved that. Okay. That was beautiful.
好吧。所以你写日记的地方是飞机上。我们的机场。明白了。你谈论的事情比飞机更多吗？好吧，很好。准备好了吗？我和我妈妈度过了一段非常美好的时光。我在家的每一个傍晚，我们都会和我的姐姐们、我的侄女以及她的小女儿一起坐在前廊上，看着日落，聊聊天。有一天，妈妈和我开车转了转我们这个只有1800人的小镇，她只是指出了不同的事情，比如谁家弄了新的车棚，或者谁搬家了，或者教会里的一对年轻夫妇如何寻找他们的第一栋房子，也许是小学旁边需要修缮的房子，或者饲料店里发生了什么，谁在冰雪皇后旁边建房子。你知道的，诸如此类的事情。我对她的每一句话都言听计从。我喜欢那样。好的。那太美了。
Thank you. Monday, March 30th, 9 a.m. LAX to Denver. Now flying with my daughter to meet up with Josh and the boys in Colorado. I'm kind of obsessed with people's travel outfits. Like today, there's the purple lady. Purple carry-on, purple tie-dye t-shirt. She's holding a purple Stanley mug.
谢谢。3月30日，星期一，上午9点。洛杉矶飞往丹佛。现在和我的女儿一起飞往科罗拉多州与乔希和男孩们会合。我对人们的旅行服装有点着迷。就像今天，有紫衣女士。紫色登机箱，紫色晕染T恤。她手里拿着一个紫色的斯坦利马克杯。
And then there's the hat ladies. They're in a group, and they're all wearing the sort of straw type of cowboy hats with ribbons. Who are these ladies? Where are they going? What are they celebrating? I think they're in their 50s. They clearly are having some type of themed vacate. I so want to go up to them and say, tell me everything.
然后是戴帽子的女士们。她们是一群人，都戴着那种带丝带的草帽。这些女士是谁？她们要去哪里？她们在庆祝什么？我想她们大概五十多岁了。她们显然在进行某种主题度假。我真想走过去对她们说，把一切都告诉我。
Still waiting for our flight. Ugh. It was delayed because of some gate issue. at a food court, I just paid $6.34 for a small bottle of water. I'm really bummed. I forgot to bring my own water bottle. And a guy in front of me ordered a lobster sandwich. Why?
还在等我们的航班。呃。因为某个登机口的问题延误了。在美食广场，我刚花6.34美元买了一小瓶水。我真的很沮丧。我忘了带自己的水瓶。我前面的一个人点了一个龙虾三明治。为什么？
I mean, seriously, why would you order a lobster sandwich at an airport? Big nope for me. It's these moments where you're like breaking the fourth wall for me. We're like, ugh, right? Everyone who's reading your drama at once, we're all frustrated. You're all frustrated. I love all the observations. Like, I truly love them.
我是说，说真的，为什么你要在机场点龙虾三明治？对我来说绝对是个大大的“不”。就是这些时刻，你对我来说就像是打破了第四堵墙。我们就像是，呃，对吧？所有同时在读你的日记的人，我们都很沮丧。你们都很沮丧。我喜欢所有的观察。真的，我真的很喜欢。
It's very, very good. Okay, well, there's one more from this entry. Okay. On our flight, there's a man across the aisle with long stringy hair, like crazy long, but he doesn't have much of it. Like, it's super thin. He has it pulled back into the saddest ponytail. I'm looking at the pen I'm riding with, and his ponytail is about the same width.
非常好，非常好。好吧，这条记录还有一个。好吧。在我们的航班上，过道对面坐着一个留着长长细碎头发的男人，长得有点疯狂，但他头发不多。就像，它超级稀疏。他把它扎成了一个最可怜的马尾辫。我看着我手里写的笔，他的马尾辫大概也就是那么粗。
Bless his heart. Oh, wow. I got a groan from Matt. Wednesday, April 1st, 259 p.m. flying from Denver to Seattle on United. Our college tours are going well. We had a great time with Josh's family in Colorado. We're waiting for our flight to Seattle to go tour the University of Washington. Josh is super excited because it's supposed to be overcast with a chance of rain there, his favorite kind of weather. Hold up. Oh my God. Right now, they are paging a passenger over the intercom at the Denver airport.
祝他好运。哦，哇。马特叹了口气。4月1日，星期三，下午2点59分。乘坐美联航从丹佛飞往西雅图。我们的大学参观很顺利。我们在科罗拉多州和乔希的家人度过了一段美好的时光。我们在等去西雅图的航班，去参观华盛顿大学。乔希超级兴奋，因为那里应该会是阴天，还有下雨的可能，这是他最喜欢的天气。等等。哦，天哪。现在，丹佛机场的对讲机正在呼叫一名乘客。
y'all this is amazing they are saying paging idris albi passenger idris albi i mean come on i need idris albi and idris elba to meet just once am i right now on our flight so on united you get a choice of three snack boxes they are ten dollars here are your options the tapas box hummus pita chips brusetta dip rosemary crackers green olives and almonds that take off box, salami, garlic and herb crustini, Gouda cheese bread, crackers, fig spread, almonds, hazelnut, wafer. The recline box, potato chips, beef and pork stick, fruit, gummy bears, Oreo, cookies, almonds. Guess what I picked?
大家伙，这太棒了。他们在说，呼叫伊德里斯·阿尔比，乘客伊德里斯·阿尔比，我是说，拜托，我需要伊德里斯·阿尔比和伊德里斯·艾尔巴见一次面，我说的对吗？现在在我们的航班上，所以坐美联航你可以从三个零食盒中选择一个，它们是十美元，以下是你的选择：小吃拼盘盒，鹰嘴豆泥、皮塔饼干、意式烤面包蘸酱、迷迭香饼干、青橄榄和杏仁；起飞盒，萨拉米香肠、大蒜香草脆饼、豪达奶酪面包、饼干、无花果酱、杏仁、榛子威化。躺椅盒，薯片、牛肉和猪肉条、水果、小熊软糖、奥利奥饼干、杏仁。你猜我选了哪个？
Anyone? The hummus one again? I got the tapas box. It was delicious. Also, just a heads up. This United Flight offered San Juan Blanc and not Chardonnay, yas. Okay. Here we go.
有人知道吗？又是鹰嘴豆泥那个？我选了小吃拼盘盒。太好吃了。另外，顺便提醒一下。这趟美联航航班提供长相思，不提供霞多丽，耶。好吧。我们开始吧。
Last entry, everybody. Friday, April 3rd, 1135 a.m. Seattle to San Francisco. Waiting for our flight, the man next to me is talking loudly on speakerphone. He's excitedly talking to someone named Claire. He keeps saying, oh, Claire, and then laughing, I sh-h-you-not. When he hangs up the phone, which I hope is soon, I want to say, so Claire and you still a thing, huh? Anyway, where was I? Oh, Seattle was amazing. First of all, wait, wait. Is anyway, where was I something you just said or did you write that down? I wrote that. I thought so. Because I think I'm talking to someone. Okay. Anyway, where was I? I'm ridiculous. Amazing. Anyway, where was I? Oh, Seattle was amazing. First of all,
最后一条记录，各位。4月3日，星期五，上午11点35分。西雅图飞往旧金山。在等航班时，我旁边的一个男人正在免提电话里大声说话。他正兴奋地和某个叫克莱尔的人说话。他不停地说，哦，克莱尔，然后大笑，我发誓我没骗你。当他挂断电话时——我希望这快点发生，我想说，所以你和克莱尔现在还是一对吗，嗯？总之，我刚才说到哪了？哦，西雅图太棒了。首先，等等，等等。“总之，我刚才说到哪了”是你刚才说的话，还是你把它写下来了？我写下来了。我也这么觉得。因为我觉得我在跟某人说话。好吧。总之，我刚才说到哪了？我很荒谬。太棒了。总之，我刚才说到哪了？哦，西雅图太棒了。首先，
it was cherry blossom season and there were rows and rows of trees blooming. We walked under this pink canopy, just gorgeous. And hands down, our favorite thing we did as a family on this trip was a floating sauna. We stayed at the Woodmark Hotel, which I kept calling the Woodward and annoying each other. It's right on Lake Washington. Thanks to Joel McHale for the recommendation. We loved it. Okay, our first day there, we went for a walk and saw these people coming out of what looked like a little house on the water.
那是樱花盛开的季节，一排排的树木正在盛开。我们走在这个粉红色的树冠下，简直美极了。毫无疑问，我们在这次旅行中作为家庭最喜欢做的事情是一个浮动桑拿房。我们住在伍德马克酒店，我一直把它叫作伍德沃德，互相惹对方生气。它就在华盛顿湖畔。感谢乔尔·麦克海尔的推荐。我们很喜欢。好的，我们在那里的第一天，去散步，看到这些人从一个看起来像水上小屋的地方走出来，
And then they ran down this long pier and jumped into the lake and howled and laughed. Josh said, whatever that is, we got to do it. Turns out you can go into these little tiny floating saunas and do a cold plunge right off the dock. They have a ladder and everything to climb back out of the water. It was called Vaughn Sana, and we did the quote, social sauna, where you just book your seat and you get an hour. So our family was paired with a couple celebrating a birthday. But I guess if you want to get fancy, you can rent the whole thing out as a private
然后他们跑过长长的栈桥，跳进湖里，大喊大叫，哈哈大笑。乔希说，不管那是什么，我们必须去做。事实证明，你可以进入这些小小的浮动桑拿房，直接在码头边进行冷水浴。他们有梯子和所有东西可以爬出水面。它叫沃恩桑拿，我们做了所谓的“社交桑拿”，你只要预订你的座位，就会有一个小时。所以我们家和一个庆祝生日的夫妇分在了一起。但我想如果你想讲究一点，你可以把整个地方包下来作为私人的
sauna experience. But the couple we met was lovely, and so save your money and go for the cheaper social sauna experience. And then I wrote, and Jenna, I know I'll read this to you, but I thought about you the whole time. You would have loved this. I wasn't sure if I had the courage to do the plunge because I hate being cold. It's a thing anyone who knows me knows about me.
桑拿体验。但我们遇到的那对夫妇很可爱，所以省下你的钱去体验更便宜的社交桑拿吧。然后我写道：珍娜，我知道我会把这个读给你听，但我一整直都在想你。你会喜欢这个的。我不确定自己是否有勇气跳下去，因为我讨厌寒冷。任何了解我的人都知道我这人这样。
My sister Janet once bought me a sweatshirt that said, I'm cold on it. But I did it. It was overcast and raining off and on and in the mid-50s outside. But we went to that little sun, and by the time we came out of there, we were so hot, and we ran down the pier and we jumped in. The whole family did it. And I asked a guy who worked there what the temperature of Lake Washington was. He said probably around 46 degrees.
我姐姐珍妮曾经给我买了一件运动衫，上面写着“我很冷”。但我做到了。天阴沉沉的，断断续续地下着雨，外面气温在50度左右（约10多摄氏度）。但我们去了那个小桑拿房，当我们从里面出来时，我们太热了，我们跑过栈桥，跳了进去。全家人都这么做了。我问一个在那工作的员工华盛顿湖的水温是多少。他说大概46度左右（约7.8摄氏度）。
Oh, M.G. Wow. I'm glad I didn't know that before I jumped in, but honestly, it felt so refreshing and invigorating. we all ran back to the sauna and then we did it all over again. Lady, can I say something about your journal? It is very clear to me why you love David Sedaris, because your writing reminds me of his writing. Oh, well, that's a huge compliment.
哦，天哪。哇。庆幸的是我跳进去之前不知道这个，但老实说，感觉太清爽、太提神了。我们都跑回桑拿房，然后又来了一遍。亲爱的，我能对你的日记说点什么吗？我很清楚你为什么喜欢大卫·塞达里思，因为你的写作让我想起了他的写作。哦，这真是个巨大的赞美。
That's very true. I never noticed that. Yes, it's true. Just all of the little slice of life details, but then you'll hit me with watching the sunset with your mom and sisters and, like, other details that just like, oh, they just tug at my heartstrings. It's such a wonderful experience. And the way it's written, the bless your heart on the tail end of the ponytail thing was like a perfect David Sedaris level button to like go to a next chapter.
这绝对是真的。我从没注意到这一点。是的，这是真的。只是所有这些生活中的小切片细节，但随后你会用与你妈妈和姐姐们看日落的场景，以及其他细节给我致命一击，哦，它们直接触动了我的心弦。这是一次非常棒的体验。而且它的写作方式，马尾辫结尾处的“祝你好运”就像是一个完美的大卫·塞达里思式的转场按钮，可以直接进入下一章。
I didn't mean to be snarky to that man, but I just was like, what's the point of that little rubber band is not holding much? But he needed it. He needed that ponytail. Yes. So, anyway, that was my travel journal. Wow. Sorry, Matt. I loved it.
我不是故意对那个男人刻薄，我只是觉得，那根小橡皮筋有什么用，根本扎不住什么？但他需要它。他需要那个马尾辫。是的。所以，总之，这就是我的旅行日记。哇。抱歉，马特。我很喜欢。
And also, I'm going to Seattle, and I'm definitely going to do that sauna. Oh, you have to. I'll share the Lincoln Stories Ball. I'll send it to you. It was great. It was not expensive. I would do it again. It looked amazing.
而且，我要去西雅图，我绝对要去做那个桑拿。哦，你一定要去。我会分享林肯的故事。我会发给你。太棒了。不贵。我还想再去一次。看起来棒极了。
Jenna, how much of your journals are about snacks? I actually have quite a bit of food in my journal. All right. Oh, good. Oh, I can't wait. I mean, you guys have never heard me read a travel journal. No, I haven't. No, I'm so excited to know this part of you.
珍娜，你的日记有多少是关于零食的？我的日记里其实有很多关于食物的内容。好吧。哦，太好了。哦，我等不及了。我是说，你们从来没听我读过旅行日记。不，我没有。不，我很高兴能了解你的这一面。
I hope you guys like it. It has a few Angela qualities, I think. We're not that different. I don't know what you'll think. Oh, it's going to be great. I feel shy. Should I start? Please. I also titled my journal travel journal. Okay. And I said, hello from Tokyo, specifically from the Imperial Hotel in Tokyo, which is the greatest hotel in the whole world for so many reasons. First, the location is great. The beds are firm, the pillows are soft. They have these blackout shades that overlap when you close them so there are no gaps. Ooh. These are the things that I appreciate in a hotel. There is a clock in the bathroom.
希望你们会喜欢。我想它有一些安吉拉的特质。我们没那么不同。我不知道你们会怎么想。哦，会很棒的。我觉得害羞。我要开始吗？请吧。我也把我的日记命名为《旅行日记》。好吧。我说，来自东京的问候，具体来说是来自东京帝国酒店，由于种种原因，它是全世界最棒的酒店。首先，地理位置很好。床很硬，枕头很软。它们有遮光窗帘，关上时会重叠，所以没有缝隙。哦。这些是我在酒店里看重的东西。浴室里有一个钟。
Thank you. Also, pajamas. They lay out pajamas each night and they have an amazing shower gel. I was going to ride on the airplane, but instead I read my book, which I am loving, the Poisonwood Bible, and I watched the running man, which is still kind of haunting me days later. And once we got here, we hit the ground running. This is probably our most ambitious travel itinerary, and I'm really impressed with how the kids have jumped in. Our first day, we toured around for 11 hours straight.
谢谢。还有，睡衣。他们每天晚上都会摆好睡衣，而且他们有一种神奇的沐浴露。我本打算在飞机上写的，但相反我读了我的书，我非常喜欢那本《毒木圣经》，我还看了《奔跑的人》，几天后它仍然让我有点难以忘怀。一旦我们到了这里，我们就马不停蹄地行动起来。这可能是我们最大胆的旅行行程，我对孩子们如何全身心投入感到非常印象深刻。第一天，我们连续参观了11个小时。
Wow. I had a little time this morning, so here we go. First of all, the thing I'm looking most forward to about this trip is being stuck all together as a family of four for two solid weeks. No work, no friends, nothing but the four of us. I'm also so excited that I don't have to manage our family calendar. For two weeks, we will all be doing the same thing all together every day. I'm excited for our actual vacation and also excited that I don't have to figure out how to get everyone to all their different activities every day. It's one calendar, one plan.
哇。我今天早上有一点时间，所以我们开始吧。首先，我对这次旅行最期待的事情是作为四口之家连续整整两个星期紧紧粘在一起。没有工作，没有朋友，只有我们四个人。我也很高兴我不用管理我们的家庭日历。两个星期里，我们将每天一起做完全相同的事情。我对我们真正的假期感到兴奋，也为我不用想方设法每天把每个人送到他们不同的活动中去而感到兴奋。这是一个日历，一个计划。
I think Lee is excited he doesn't have to cook any food. He does breakfast for everyone each morning, and I'm currently watching him sip coffee and look out the window at the Tokyo Skyline and I can tell he's so happy he doesn't have to take anyone's breakfast order. Also, I am most comfortable in my little family unit. I don't get social anxiety. I feel really safe. Two weeks of immersing in this part of my life is heaven. Oh, that's so truly you, lady.
我想李很高兴他不用做饭。他每天早上为每个人做早餐，我目前正看着他啜饮咖啡，凝望着东京的天空线，我能看出他非常高兴不用点任何人的早餐。另外，在我的小家庭里我最感到舒适。我没有社交焦虑。我感到非常安全。沉浸在我生活的这一部分两个星期简直是天堂。哦，这太真的是你的风格了，亲爱的。
Yeah, that was very, um, is it the scientific method that you learn in school where it's like observation, ask a question, research, form a hypothesis, conduct an experiment. analyze, draw conclusions, and then communicate results. That's yours. It's perfectly to a T. This is where I was. This is what I saw. Well, I go on. I say, it's only our second day here, and we have already been laughing a lot and making
Yeah, that was very, um, is it the scientific method that you learn in school where it's like observation, ask a question, research, form a hypothesis, conduct an experiment. analyze, draw conclusions, and then communicate results. That's yours. It's perfectly to a T. This is where I was. This is what I saw. Well, I go on. I say, it's only our second day here, and we have already been laughing a lot and making|||是的，那非常，嗯，这是你在学校里学的科学方法吗，比如观察、提问、研究、形成假设、进行实验、分析、得出结论，然后交流结果。那是你的。完全一模一样。这就是我在的地方。这就是我看到的。好吧，我继续说。我说，这才是我们在这里的第二天，我们已经笑了很多次，而且留下了
inside jokes and family memories. Act, I just love it. It was a little brutal our first night. We didn't sleep on the plane, but we arrived at 7 p.m. and just had to stay awake for a few hours. We did it. People were a little short time. tempered that first day. We spent a lot of time figuring out how to buy a train ticket to see this
inside jokes and family memories. Act, I just love it. It was a little brutal our first night. We didn't sleep on the plane, but we arrived at 7 p.m. and just had to stay awake for a few hours. We did it. People were a little short time. tempered that first day. We spent a lot of time figuring out how to buy a train ticket to see this|||内部笑话和家庭回忆。真的，我太喜欢了。我们的第一晚有点残酷。我们在飞机上没睡觉，但我们晚上7点到达，只能再熬几个小时。我们做到了。第一天人们的脾气有点急躁。我们花了很长时间研究怎么买火车票去看这个
giant Buddha. When you are jet-legged, it makes machines even harder to understand. Me, Lee, and Weston were able to use this app on our phone, but it wouldn't let Harper use it because she's under 13. So we had to get her a physical ticket or card every time we rode the train. That was a whole thing. The train ride to the Buddha was long, and the Buddha was fine, but maybe not worth two hours there and two hours back on a train. Sorry, Giant Buddha. We didn't. enjoy the little town and had a pretty cool lunch. This is something that would also be great on TripAdvisor. Yeah, this is perfect. Okay. Everyone is in a good mood today after a good night's sleep and a great breakfast buffet. I'm not sure it gets better than a breakfast buffet on vacation.
giant Buddha. When you are jet-legged, it makes machines even harder to understand. Me, Lee, and Weston were able to use this app on our phone, but it wouldn't let Harper use it because she's under 13. So we had to get her a physical ticket or card every time we rode the train. That was a whole thing. The train ride to the Buddha was long, and the Buddha was fine, but maybe not worth two hours there and two hours two hours back on a train. Sorry, Giant Buddha. We didn't. enjoy the little town and had a pretty cool lunch. This is something that would also be great on TripAdvisor. Yeah, this is perfect. Okay. Everyone is in a good mood today after a good night's sleep and a great breakfast buffet. I'm not sure it gets better than a breakfast buffet on vacation.|||大佛。当你有时差时，机器就更难懂了。我和李还有韦斯顿可以用手机上的这个应用，但它不让哈珀用，因为她不到13岁。所以我们每次坐火车都得给她买一张实体票或卡。这可真是一件麻烦事。去大佛的火车旅程很长，大佛还行，但可能不值得在火车上单程花两个小时。对不起，大佛。我们没有。我们很喜欢那个小镇，还吃了顿挺棒的午餐。这也是个很适合发在猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）上的地方。对，这太完美了。好吧。今天大家昨晚睡了个好觉，又吃了丰盛的自助早餐，心情都很好。我不确定度假时的自助早餐还能有什么更棒的了。
Something that has already surprised me is just how darn good the pineapple is in Japan. I looked it up, and I read that 90% of Japan's pineapples are grown in Okinawa, and that, yes, they are really sweet. And I can confirm. Also, Japanese melon, which I can't quite figure out. It's sort of like honeydew melon, but not exactly. It's also really sweet and delicious. The coffee here is good, but they only served us one small cup at breakfast, and they didn't come around and ask if we wanted more. And I think it's because maybe the Japanese don't pound coffee like Americans do, because I remember being in France, and their whole thing is like, one small great cup of coffee is all you need.
Something that has already surprised me is just how darn good the pineapple is in Japan. I looked it up, and I read that 90% of Japan's pineapples are grown in Okinawa, and that, yes, they are really sweet. And I can confirm. Also, Japanese melon, which I can't quite figure out. It's sort of like honeydew melon, but not exactly. It's also really sweet and delicious. The coffee here is good, but they only served us one small cup at breakfast, and they didn't come around and ask if we wanted more. And I think it's because maybe the Japanese don't pound coffee like Americans do, because I remember being in France, and their whole thing is like, one small great cup of coffee is all you need.|||有一件事已经让我感到惊奇，那就是日本的菠萝简直太好吃了。我查了一下，上面说日本90%的菠萝都产自冲绳，而且确实非常甜。我可以证实这一点。还有日本的甜瓜，我有点搞不懂。它有点像哈密瓜，但又不完全是。它也非常甜非常好吃。这里的咖啡不错，但早餐时他们只给我们端来了一小杯，也没有过来问我们还要不要。我想这可能是因为日本人不像美国人那样狂喝咖啡，因为我记得在法国时，他们的整个理念就是，一杯美味的小咖啡就足够了。
And I'm like, I beg to differ. I'm used to three or four decent cups of coffee. Anyway, this has become a real tangent, but I am fascinated by cultural differences when I travel. Oh, like, for example, there are no trash cans in Japan. They were removed after the subway gas bombing of 1995. So, if you acquire any trash in your day, you have to carry it around until you get home.
And I'm like, I beg to differ. I'm used to three or four decent cups of coffee. Anyway, this has become a real tangent, but I am fascinated by cultural differences when I travel. Oh, like, for example, there are no trash cans in Japan. They were removed after the subway gas bombing of 1995. So, if you acquire any trash in your day, you have to carry it around until you get home.|||而我想说，恕我不敢苟同。我习惯喝三四杯不错的咖啡。不管怎样，这已经扯远了，但我旅行时对文化差异非常着迷。哦，比如，日本没有垃圾桶。它们是在1995年地铁沙林毒气事件后被撤走的。所以，如果你在白天制造了任何垃圾，你都必须随身携带，直到回到家。
Like, let's say you get a Starbucks. First of all, no one walks around and eats or walks around and drinks in Japan. You can get a food or drink item to go, but you have to just stand to the side and eat or drink. Also, no eating or drinking on the trains. On the bullet train, it's okay, but not on the subway. So let's say you grab a hot can of coffee from 7-Eleven.
Like, let's say you get a Starbucks. First of all, no one walks around and eats or walks around and drinks in Japan. You can get a food or drink item to go, but you have to just stand to the side and eat or drink. Also, no eating or drinking on the trains. On the bullet train, it's okay, but not on the subway. So let's say you grab a hot can of coffee from 7-Eleven.|||比如，假设你买了一杯星巴克。首先，在日本没有人边走边吃或边走边喝。你可以买外带的食物或饮料，但你必须站在一旁吃或喝。此外，车上严禁饮食。在子弹头列车（新干线）上可以，但在地铁上不行。所以假设你从7-11便利店拿了一罐热咖啡。
Because that's another thing. The 7-Elevens have hot cans of coffee. There's 7-Elevens? Oh, yeah, famously 7-Elevens. Yeah, they're huge there. And they have all these snacks and sushi. Yeah, the 7-Eleven, is it egg salad? It's supposed to be world-ren-out.
Because that's another thing. The 7-Elevens have hot cans of coffee. There's 7-Elevens? Oh, yeah, famously 7-Elevens. Yeah, they're huge there. And they have all these snacks and sushi. Yeah, the 7-Eleven, is it egg salad? It's supposed to be world-ren-out.|||因为这是另一回事。7-11里有热罐咖啡。有7-11吗？哦，对，非常有名的7-11。对，它们在那里的规模很大。而且它们有各种零食和寿司。对，7-11的那个，是鸡蛋沙拉三明治吗？据说那是世界闻名的。
You guys, I didn't eat it. Can you believe it? Me, lover of eggs, every day, my son was like, Mom, are you going to get that egg salad sandwich today? And every time I was like, I just don't feel like eating eggs right now. It was always like full in the moment. And you can't walk and eat, so you have to, like, want to eat. eat it right then, you know? Yeah. So I can't believe I went all the way to Japan and I didn't
You guys, I didn't eat it. Can you believe it? Me, lover of eggs, every day, my son was like, Mom, are you going to get that egg salad sandwich today? And every time I was like, I just don't feel like eating eggs right now. It was always like full in the moment. And you can't walk and eat, so you have to, like, want to eat. eat it right then, you know? Yeah. So I can't believe I went all the way to Japan and I didn't|||伙计们，我居然没吃。你们敢信吗？我这个鸡蛋爱好者，每天我儿子都问：妈妈，你今天要买那个鸡蛋沙拉三明治吗？每一次我都回答：我这会儿就是不想吃鸡蛋。当时总是感觉饱饱的。而且你不能边走边吃，所以你必须得是，当时就特别想吃，懂吗？对。所以我简直不敢相信我大老远去了日本，竟然没
eat the egg salad sandwich. But anyway, okay, back to my journal. There's a whole section that looks like it's refrigerated and filled with cans, but actually they are all hot. So let's say you get a hot can of coffee. You stand and drink it. And when you're done, zero trash cans. You have to carry that can around. You might be thinking, could I throw it away in a public restroom? Because I thought that. I thought there might be a trash can in there. No. Most public restrooms didn't have paper towels or trash bins. They had hand dryers. And if they did have a trash bin, it is not considered polite to throw anything other than feminine products or paper towels in it. So you carry around your trash in a bag, in your purse, in your pocket. I found it sort of
eat the egg salad sandwich. But anyway, okay, back to my journal. There's a whole section that looks like it's refrigerated and filled with cans, but actually they are all hot. So let's say you get a hot can of coffee. You stand and drink it. And when you're done, zero trash cans. You have to carry that can around. You might be thinking, could I throw it away in a public restroom? Because I thought that. I thought there might be a trash can in there. No. Most public restrooms didn't have paper towels or trash bins. They had hand dryers. And if they did have a trash bin, it is not considered polite to throw anything other than feminine products or paper towels in it. So you carry around your trash in a bag, in your purse, in your pocket. I found it sort of|||吃那个鸡蛋沙拉三明治。不过无论如何，好吧，回到我的日记。有一个区域看起来像是冷藏的，里面摆满了罐装饮料，但实际上它们全都是热的。所以假设你拿了一罐热咖啡。你站着把它喝完。喝完后，垃圾桶数量为零。你必须把那个空罐子随身带着。你可能会想，我能把它扔在公共厕所里吗？因为我也这么想过。我以为里面可能会有垃圾桶。并没有。大多数公共厕所既没有纸巾也没有垃圾桶。它们有干手机。如果它们确实有垃圾桶，往里面扔除了女性用品或纸巾之外的任何东西都被认为是不礼貌的。所以你只能把垃圾装在袋子里、钱包里或口袋里随身携带。我发现这有点
fascinating because you really get a sense of how much trash you produce when you're forced to carry it around with you all day. And here's the other thing. The city is spotless. Everyone picks up after themselves. I was actually trying to imagine a Japanese person going to New York City and seeing the city through their eyes and I shuddered at the thought. And listen, I love New York, but it's so dirty.
fascinating because you really get a sense of how much trash you produce when you're forced to carry it around with you all day. And here's the other thing. The city is spotless. Everyone picks up after themselves. I was actually trying to imagine a Japanese person going to New York City and seeing the city through their eyes and I shuddered at the thought. And listen, I love New York, but it's so dirty.|||引人入胜，因为当你被迫整天随身携带垃圾时，你真的能真切地感受到自己产生了多少垃圾。还有一件事。这座城市一尘不染。每个人都会自己收拾好垃圾。我其实一直在想象一个日本人去纽约市，通过他们的视角来看这座城市，一想到这儿我不禁打了个寒战。听着，我爱纽约，但它真的太脏了。
Okay, I should go. I'll write more later if I'm able. Aha! You were talking to your journal. I was. I was your friend. Okay, I got to go. I hope you guys realize both of these fit together like puzzle pieces.
Okay, I should go. I'll write more later if I'm able. Aha! You were talking to your journal. I was. I was your friend. Okay, I got to go. I hope you guys realize both of these fit together like puzzle pieces.|||好了，我该走了。如果可以的话，我待会儿再写。啊哈！你在跟你的日记对话呢。我是。我是你的朋友。好了，我得走了。我希望你们意识到，这两篇日记就像拼图一样完美地契合在一起。
If you erase the places that you went, this could be the same story. Yours is all about how you got there with nothing about what you did when you were there. I talk about it in hindsight what I did in places. True, but not to the extent of Jenna's. You didn't mention once how everyone's moods were. No, I didn't talk about like other people. I didn't talk about my family dynamics. You just see that you fill in each other's stories like that.
If you erase the places that you went, this could be the same story. Yours is all about how you got there with nothing about what you did when you were there. I talk about it in hindsight what I did in places. True, but not to the extent of Jenna's. You didn't mention once how everyone's moods were. No, I didn't talk about like other people. I didn't talk about my family dynamics. You just see that you fill in each other's stories like that.|||如果你抹去你们去过的地方，这简直就是同一个故事。你的日记全都是关于你是怎么到达那里的，而完全没有你在那里做了什么。我是事后回顾我在那些地方做了什么。确实如此，但没有詹娜那么详细。你一次也没提过大家的精神状态怎么样。没有，我没谈到其他人。我没谈到我的家庭动态。你们看，你们就这样填补了彼此的故事。
Maybe this is why we're BFFs. I know. This is why our points of view meld so well together into a podcast. We compliment it all. We do. I have more. Please. Okay.
Maybe this is why we're BFFs. I know. This is why our points of view meld so well together into a podcast. We compliment it all. We do. I have more. Please. Okay.|||也许这就是我们为什么是死党的原因。我知道。这就是为什么我们的观点能如此完美地融合成一个播客。我们完美互补。确实如此。我还有更多。请吧。好的。
I want you to read the entire thing. Okay. Here's the rest of it. Ready? We love Tokyo. We head to Kyoto tomorrow and we kind of wish we had another day here. Lee and I came years ago, just the two of us, and we liked it. But visiting it again, we've fallen in love.
I want you to read the entire thing. Okay. Here's the rest of it. Ready? We love Tokyo. We head to Kyoto tomorrow and we kind of wish we had another day here. Lee and I came years ago, just the two of us, and we liked it. But visiting it again, we've fallen in love.|||我想让你把整篇都读完。好的。这是剩下的部分。准备好了吗？我们爱东京。我们明天出发去京都，真有点希望在这里再多待一天。我和李多年前来过，就我们俩，当时我们就很喜欢。但再次造访，我们已经深深爱上了这里。
One of the things we are discovering is how vertical. cold the city is. You have to get off the ground level. The best stores and restaurants are up. The other night we ate at a Wagyu barbecue place near Uwano Park, and one of the best parts of the meal was riding the elevator to the 11th floor. We stopped at a bunch of floors along the way, and every time the doors opened, they opened into a different restaurant. Oh, cool. And you would get this tiny glimpse into a whole new world, a whole vibe with new smells and sounds, and then the doors would shut and take you up to the next spot. I wanted to stop at every floor. One time the doors opened on a giant fish tank. That's all just a fish tank. We are still all talking about it days later.
One of the things we are discovering is how vertical. cold the city is. You have to get off the ground level. The best stores and restaurants are up. The other night we ate at a Wagyu barbecue place near Uwano Park, and one of the best parts of the meal was riding the elevator to the 11th floor. We stopped at a bunch of floors along the way, and every time the doors opened, they opened into a different restaurant. Oh, cool. And you would get this tiny glimpse into a whole new world, a whole vibe with new smells and sounds, and then the doors would shut and take you up to the next spot. I wanted to stop at every floor. One time the doors opened on a giant fish tank. That's all just a fish tank. We are still all talking about it days later.|||我们发现的一件事是这座城市的垂直度。你必须离开地面。最好的商店和餐厅都在楼上。前天晚上我们在上野公园附近的一家和牛烤肉店吃饭，这顿饭最棒的体验之一就是坐电梯到11楼。我们在中途停了好几层，每次门一打开，都会通往一家不同的餐厅。哦，太酷了。你会瞥见一个全新的世界，一种充满新气味和新声音的全新氛围，然后电梯门关上，把你带到下一个地方。我想在每一层都停下来。有一次，电梯门打开时正对着一个巨大的鱼缸。里面全都是鱼缸。几天后我们大家还在谈论这件事。
And I keep thinking about it. It was like riding in a real life, choose your own adventure book, each stop having the potential to change your destiny. Another highlight of the trip was going to the Tokyo Dome to see the Tokyo Giants play the Tigers. I don't know where the tigers were from, but I know it was the Giants versus the Tigers, and this is a big rivalry. We got to the game and bought some Giants hats and we're all so excited, and then we realized we were sitting in the Tigers section. Oh, no! So it was kind of hilarious, because they have dedicated sections for fans, and they have all these chants they do during the game. It reminded me of the chance at the L-AFC soccer games, just constant chanting, but so fun. There is a small theme park surrounding the dome. It is smaller than
And I keep thinking about it. It was like riding in a real life, choose your own adventure book, each stop having the potential to change your destiny. Another highlight of the trip was going to the Tokyo Dome to see the Tokyo Giants play the Tigers. I don't know where the tigers were from, but I know it was the Giants versus the Tigers, and this is a big rivalry. We got to the game and bought some Giants hats and we're all so excited, and then we realized we were sitting in the Tigers section. Oh, no! So it was kind of hilarious, because they have dedicated sections for fans, and they have all these chants they do during the game. It reminded me of the chance at the L-AFC soccer games, just constant chanting, but so fun. There is a small theme park surrounding the dome. It is smaller than|||我一直在回想。这就像是在现实生活中阅读一本“选择你自己的冒险”的书，每一站都有可能改变你的命运。这次旅行的另一个亮点是去东京巨蛋观看东京巨人队对阵阪神老虎队的比赛。我不知道老虎队来自哪里，但我知道那是巨人队对阵老虎队，这是一场宿敌之战。我们到了比赛现场，买了一些巨人队的帽子，大家都兴奋极了，然后我们意识到我们坐在了老虎队的球迷区。哦，不！所以这有点滑稽，因为他们有专门的球迷区，他们在比赛中有各种助威口号。这让我想起了洛杉矶FC（LAFC）足球比赛时的口号，就是不停地呐喊，但超级有趣。巨蛋周围有一个小型主题乐园。它比|||六旗乐园（Six Flags）或迪士尼乐园要小，但他们确实
Six Flags or Disneyland, but they do. have a log flume ride and one of those big swinging pirate ships. And it has one of the tallest continuous roller coasters in the world currently ranked number 10. Lee went on it with Harper. Oh, they loved it. They said the initial drop was insane. And of course, there was a place with the gazillion crane machines. We spent a lot of yen trying to win a plushy but went home empty-handed. Maybe the coolest thing we did in Tokyo was our Shibuya food tour. We had a local guide take us through the underground food stalls of the food show beneath Shibuya train station. He explained that all of the food stalls were pop-up versions of some of the best restaurants
have a log flume ride and one of those big swinging pirate ships. And it has one of the tallest continuous roller coasters in the world currently ranked number 10. Lee on it with Harper. Oh, they loved it. They said the initial drop was insane. And of course, there was a place with the gazillion crane machines. We spent a lot of yen trying to win a plushy but went home empty-handed. Maybe the coolest thing we did in Tokyo was our Shibuya food tour. We had a local guide take us through the underground food stalls of the food show beneath Shibuya train station. He explained that all of the food stalls were pop-up versions of some of the best restaurants|||有一个激流勇进项目和一个巨大的海盗船。这里还有世界上最高的连续过山车之一，目前排名第十。李和哈珀一起去坐了。哦，他们太喜欢了。他们说最初的下落简直疯狂。当然，还有一个摆满了无数抓娃娃机的地方。我们花了好多日元想赢得一个毛绒玩具，结果却空手而归。我们在东京做的最酷的事情可能就是我们的涩谷美食之旅了。我们请了一位当地导游，带我们穿过涩谷火车站地下的“美食秀”地下美食摊位。他解释说，所有的美食摊位都是东京一些最好餐厅的快闪版本。
from the best chefs in Tokyo. There was a place selling bento boxes made by a three-star Michelin chef. Our first stop was a six-stool ramen place that had been voted Best Chicken Ramen in Tokyo for several years in a row. You're making me so hungry. Also, you're describing a place I've always wanted to go to. I know exactly what you're referencing right now. Sam, it was amazing.
from the best chefs in Tokyo. There was a place selling bento boxes made by a three-star Michelin chef. Our first stop was a six-stool ramen place that had been voted Best Chicken Ramen in Tokyo for several years in a row. You're making me so hungry. Also, you're describing a place I've always wanted to go to. I know exactly what you're referencing right now. Sam, it was amazing.|||出自东京最顶级的主厨之手。有一个摊位在卖由米其林三星主厨制作的便当。我们的第一站是一家只有六个座位、连续几年被评为东京最佳鸡肉拉面店的拉面馆。你把我说的太饿了。而且，你描述的地方正是我一直想去的地方。我完全知道你现在说的是哪里。萨姆，那太棒了。
That's the next line in my journal. And it was amazing. Sam, it was amazing. Yeah. They served the ramen with a slice of lemon, and we were told to squeeze the lemon into the bowl about halfway through as a way to change the flavor complexity of the broth. Afterward, our guide walked us through the supermarket attached to the food stalls.
That's the next line in my journal. And it was amazing. Sam, it was amazing. Yeah. They served the ramen with a slice of lemon, and we were told to squeeze the lemon into the bowl about halfway through as a way to change the flavor complexity of the broth. Afterward, our guide walked us through the supermarket attached to the food stalls.|||这正是我日记里的下一句。太棒了。萨姆，那太棒了。是的。他们的拉面配有一片柠檬，服务员告诉我们吃到一半左右时把柠檬汁挤进碗里，以此来改变汤底的风味层次。之后，导游带我们参观了美食摊位旁边的超市。
He showed us these fancy cantaloupes that cost around $70 or $80. Whoa. He said the Japanese give fruit as a gift, and the nicer looking the fruit, the higher the price, even though they taste the same. With the cantaloupe, the deeper the grooves, the more expensive. He also said, if someone is in the hospital, you give fruit or cut flowers, but never planted flowers or anything with roots, because that implies you want them to put down roots in their illness. The hospital? Oh. Mm-hmm. We ended with a trip to a Tempaniaki restaurant. We were the only tour. there. No one spoke English, no English menu. So it's a good thing we were with him. I feel like we would have been too intimidated to go to this restaurant otherwise. He ordered all the food and it was seriously all amazing. My favorite were the meat-stuffed green peppers, the fried ginger root, and the chicken thighs. We are so sad to leave Tokyo. We wanted to ride more elevators and see what the doors opened on to. I really wish I could have explored more of the Shibuya and the food market. I wanted to buy one of those bento boxes to eat on the train.
He showed us these fancy cantaloupes that cost around $70 or $80. Whoa. He said the Japanese give fruit as a gift, and the nicer looking the fruit, the higher the price, even though they taste the same. With the cantaloupe, the deeper the grooves, the more expensive. He also said, if someone is in the hospital, you give fruit or cut flowers, but never planted flowers or anything with roots, because that implies you want them to put down roots in their illness. The hospital? Oh. Mm-hmm. We ended with a trip to a Tempaniaki restaurant. We were the only tour. there. No one spoke English, no English menu. So it's a good thing we were with him. I feel like we would have been too intimidated to go to this restaurant otherwise. He ordered all the food and it was seriously all amazing. My favorite were the meat-stuffed green peppers, the fried ginger root, and the chicken thighs. We are so sad to leave Tokyo. We wanted to ride more elevators and see what the doors opened on to. I really wish I could have explored more of the Shibuya and the food market. I wanted to buy one of those bento boxes to eat on the train.|||他给我们看了这些售价大约70到80美元的高级哈密瓜。哇。他说日本人把水果当作礼物送人，水果看起来越好看，价格就越高，尽管它们的味道都一样。对于哈密瓜来说，纹路越深就越贵。他还说，如果有人住院，你要送水果或切花，但绝对不能送盆栽花卉或任何带根的东西，因为那暗示着你想让他们在病情中“扎根”。住院？哦。嗯哼。我们的最后一站是一家铁板烧（Tempaniaki）餐厅。我们是那里的唯一一拨游客。没有人会说英语，也没有英文菜单。所以幸好我们跟他在一起。我觉得否则我们会被这家餐厅吓退而不敢进去。他点了所有的菜，真的全都太棒了。我最喜欢的是肉酿青椒、炸生姜根和鸡大腿。我们要离开东京了，心里很难过。我们还想坐更多电梯，看看门打开后会是什么样的风景。我真希望自己能探索更多涩谷和美食市场。我本来想买那些便当在火车上吃。
tomorrow, but they made it very clear you had to eat at the same day. Maybe one day. I am excited to get out into nature a bit, and we have fun stuff planned for Kyoto. We are going to make pottery with a local artist, and then he fires the pieces and sends them back home to us. I can't wait. This has already been an incredible trip, and we are making great memories. Oh, I love that, lady.
tomorrow, but they made it very clear you had to eat at the same day. Maybe one day. I am excited to get out into nature a bit, and we have fun stuff planned for Kyoto. We are going to make pottery with a local artist, and then he fires the pieces and sends them back home to us. I can't wait. This has already been an incredible trip, and we are making great memories. Oh, I love that, lady.|||明天吃，但他们明确表示必须在当天吃完。也许总有一天吧。我很兴奋能去大自然中走走，我们为京都计划了很有趣的活动。我们要和一位当地艺术家一起做陶艺，然后他把作品烧好后寄回我们家。我等不及了。这已经是一次不可思议的旅行了，我们正在创造美好的回忆。哦，我太喜欢这个了，女士。
And guys, I have to tell you, when it was time for us to fly home, our flight was delayed by five hours. So we got to spend extra time in Tokyo. We went back to the Shibuya food show. And I got that bento box. And it was so good. And they're not expensive. That's part of the thing about these food stalls. That was one of Anthony Bourdain's favorite spots. That's why I know about it. Yeah. He raves about it. I mean, I never wanted to leave. They also had this crazy thing. They have lockers. So like if in the morning you want to go shopping and buy stuff. You can put it in the locker and they're refrigerated. Oh, nice. They have refrigerated lockers. And they have a little section where you can like warm stuff up in a microwave and eat it. That's incredible. Amazing. So smart. Well, Jenna, I loved your journal. And it's like
And guys, I have to tell you, when it was time for us to fly home, our flight was delayed by five hours. So we got to spend extra time in Tokyo. We went back to the Shibuya food show. And I got that bento box. And it was so good. And they're not expensive. That's part of the thing about these food stalls. That was one of Anthony Bourdain's favorite spots. That's why I know about it. Yeah. He raves about it. I mean, I never wanted to leave. They also had this crazy thing. They have lockers. So like if in the morning you want to go shopping and buy stuff. You can put it in the locker and they're refrigerated. Oh, nice. They have refrigerated lockers. And they have a little section where you can like warm stuff up in a microwave and eat it. That's incredible. Amazing. So smart. Well, Jenna, I loved your journal. And it's like|||伙计们，我必须告诉你们，当我们准备飞回家时，我们的航班延误了五个小时。所以我们在东京得到了额外的时间。我们回到了涩谷的美食秀。我买到了那个便当。真的太好吃了。而且它们并不贵。这就是这些美食摊位的特色之一。那是安东尼·波登（Anthony Bourdain）最喜欢的地方之一。这就是我为什么知道它的原因。对。他对它赞不绝口。我是说，我根本不想离开。他们还有一个疯狂的地方。他们有储物柜。所以如果早上你想去购物买东西。你可以把它放在储物柜里，而且它们是冷藏的。哦，太棒了。他们有冷藏储物柜。他们还有一个小区域，你可以在那里用微波炉加热东西吃。太不可思议了。太棒了。太聪明了。好吧，詹娜，我很喜欢你的日记。它就像|||一个猫途鹰指南加上美好的细节的结合体。但听到你为自己的家人感到如此幸福，我真的很喜欢。哦，谢谢。好吧，我爱你。好吧，我喜欢你的日记。我真的超爱。倒不是说我们需要证明日记有多重要，但我们确实收到了两封信，我想跟你分享一下，安吉拉，因为它们真的触动了我的心，而且都是关于你的日记的。来自纽约萨拉托加泉的凯利·W（Kaylee W.）说：我在2022年开始听你们的播客，当时我女儿刚出生，我整晚不睡地喂奶和用吸奶器。你们这些女士陪伴我度过了漫长的夜晚，对此我永远心存感激。
a combination of like a trip advisor and like just wonderful specific details. But then just hearing your heart being so happy with your family. I loved it. Oh, thank you. Well, I love you. Well, I love your journaling. I truly love it. And not that we need to justify the importance of journals, but we did get two letters, and I want to share them with you, Angela, because they really touched my heart and they are about your journaling. Kaley W. from Sarasota Springs, New York, said, I started listening to your podcast in 2022 when my daughter was born and I was up all night breastfeeding and pumping. You ladies kept me company through the long nights, and I I am forever grateful for that.
Fast forward, my daughter's almost three, and she's had a tough time falling asleep lately, so I've been popping in an air pod and listening to old episodes. Last night, I was listening to Episode 139, christening, and I knew I had to write in. I was laying in bed trying to be so quiet, waiting for my daughter to settle
Fast forward, my daughter's almost three, and she's had a tough time falling asleep lately, so I've been popping in an air pod and listening to old episodes. Last night, I was listening to Episode 139, christening, and I knew I had to write in. I was laying in bed trying to be so quiet, waiting for my daughter to settle|||快进到现在，我女儿快三岁了，最近她很难入睡，所以我一直塞着AirPod听以前的单集。昨晚，我在听第139集《洗礼》，我知道我必须写信来了。我躺在床上极力保持安静，等待我女儿平静下来
when Angela started reading her journal entries. I burst into laughter and had to get it under control so fast. I legitimately felt like I was going to cry from trying to stifle my laugh. And I wanted to write you both for a couple of reasons. My husband and I recently started talking about how we find our daughter so unique, funny, and passionate, and we don't want her to ever lose that sense of herself. But no, it often happens when kids start school.
when Angela started reading her journal entries. I burst into laughter and had to get it under control so fast. I legitimately felt like I was going to cry from trying to stifle my laugh. And I wanted to write you both for a couple of reasons. My husband and I recently started talking about how we find our daughter so unique, funny, and passionate, and we don't want her to ever lose that sense of herself. But no, it often happens when kids start school.|||这时安吉拉开始朗读她的日记。我突然笑出声来，不得不以最快的速度克制住。因为极力憋笑，我真的感觉自己快要哭了。我想给你们俩写信有几个原因。我和丈夫最近开始讨论，我们觉得我们的女儿是如此独特、有趣且充满热情，我们不希望她失去自我意识。但往往当孩子们开始上学时，这种情况就会发生。
Personally, I can never even reread my old journal entries because I feel too embarrassed. hearing you do it on such a public platform. This choked me up, Angela, because this is true. Kaylee said, hearing you do it on such a public platform made me stop and think about how I hope my daughter is that confident in herself. And I am going to do my best to instill that in her. Because it's true. That is you giving us your whole. self, and that takes a lot of courage, and it takes a lot of confidence. And I love that
Personally, I can never even reread my old journal entries because I feel too embarrassed. hearing you do it on such a public platform. This choked me up, Angela, because this is true. Kaylee said, hearing you do it on such a public platform made me stop and think about how I hope my daughter is that confident in herself. And I am going to do my best to instill that in her. Because it's true. That is you giving us your whole. self, and that takes a lot of courage, and it takes a lot of confidence. And I love that|||就我个人而言，我甚至从来不敢重读我以前的日记，因为我觉得太尴尬了。听到你在这样一个公开的平台上这样做。这让我哽咽了，安吉拉，因为这是真的。凯利说，听到你在这样一个公开的平台上这样做，让我停下来思考，我多么希望我的女儿也能如此自信。我要尽最大努力把这一点灌输给她。因为这是真的。那是你向我们展示了你完整的自我，这需要很大的勇气，也需要很大的自信。我喜欢
Kaylee pointed that out. Oh, Kaylee, thank you so much. All right, here's one more. Andy D. from Georgia said, hello, I want to say, I know Angela gets a lot of grief for her journal entries, but those kind of documents are things that historians love because they document in detail normal life activities that are difficult to get just from general historical records. If when the zombie apocalypse that Jenna is always prepping for happens, the people putting humanity back together are going to be thrilled to find Angela's journals. Oh, no. I love you guys very much.
Kaylee pointed that out. Oh, Kaylee, thank you so much. All right, here's one more. Andy D. from Georgia said, hello, I want to say, I know Angela gets a lot of grief for her journal entries, but those kind of documents are things that historians love because they document in detail normal life activities that are difficult to get just from general historical records. If when the zombie apocalypse that Jenna is always prepping for happens, the people putting humanity back together are going to be thrilled to find Angela's journals. Oh, no. I love you guys very much.|||凯利指出了这一点。哦，凯利，非常感谢你。好的，还有最后一封。来自佐治亚州的安迪·D（Andy D.）说：你好，我想说，我知道安吉拉因为她的日记遭到了不少吐槽，但这类文献正是历史学家们的最爱，因为它们详细记录了普通的生活活动，而这些活动很难从一般的历史记录中获得。如果詹娜一直为之做准备的丧尸末日真的爆发了，那些重组人类文明的人将会非常高兴能找到安吉拉的日记。哦，不。我非常爱你们。
Thank you for all you do. That's so sweet. Thank you for writing in both of you guys. That's very funny to think about. I'm like picturing a whole new civilization, like whenever they see a tiny ponytail saying, bless their heart. Because they'll think that's what you're supposed to do. You're supposed to do. Well, should we take a break?
Thank you for all you do. That's so sweet. Thank you for writing in both of you guys. That's very funny to think about. I'm like picturing a whole new civilization, like whenever they see a tiny ponytail saying, bless their heart. Because they'll think that's what you're supposed to do. You're supposed to do. Well, should we take a break?|||谢谢你们所做的一切。太暖心了。谢谢你们俩写信来。一想到那个画面就觉得很好笑。我仿佛在想象一个全新的文明，每当他们看到一个小马尾辫时就会说“愿上帝保佑他们”。因为他们会认为这就是你应该做的。你本来就该这么做。好了，我们要不要休息一下？
And then when we come back, we will do our Around the Town and Office Question of the Week. All right. We're back. And our first Around the Town comes all the way from Louis England. Loic T. writes and says, hi, office ladies. I've been a listener since day one and have enjoyed every episode since. I thought I'd let you know about one of the biggest sources of pride from our small town in East Sussex, Louis. The local ladies football team.
And then when we come back, we will do our Around the Town and Office Question of the Week. All right. We're back. And our first Around the Town comes all the way from Louis England. Loic T. writes and says, hi, office ladies. I've been a listener since day one and has enjoyed every episode since. I thought I'd let you know about one of the biggest sources of pride from our small town in East Sussex, Louis. The local ladies football team.|||然后等我们回来后，我们将进行“走过大街小巷”（Around the Town）和“本周办公室问题”环节。好的。我们回来了。我们的第一个“走过大街小巷”来自遥远的英国刘易斯（Lewes）。洛伊克·T（Loic T.）来信说：嗨，办公室女士们。我是从第一天开始的听众，之后每一集都很喜欢。我想让你们知道我们东萨塞克斯郡的小镇刘易斯最大的自豪之源是什么。当地的女子足球队。
I believe you may call them a soccer team. In 2017, Lewis FC became the first football club in the entire world to pay the women's team the same as the men's. Woo-hoo! The investment, of course, paid off as a real. rose up to a championship level in 2018. I'd also like to shout out the pies and pints from local brewery Harvys founded in 1790, at their grounds, the dripping pan, which makes for a fabulous weekend outing. Keep up the good work, Loic.
I believe you may call them a soccer team. In 2017, Lewis FC became the first football club in the entire world to pay the women's team the same as the men's. Woo-hoo! The investment, of course, paid off as a real. rose up to a championship level in 2018. I'd also like to shout out the pies and pints from local brewery Harvys founded in 1790, at their grounds, the dripping pan, which makes for a fabulous weekend outing. Keep up the good work, Loic.|||我相信你们可能会称她们为英式足球队（soccer team）。2017年，刘易斯足球俱乐部（Lewis FC）成为全世界第一家向女子球队支付与男子球队相同薪酬的足球俱乐部。呜呼！这项投资当然得到了回报，球队在2018年真正崛起达到了冠军水平。我还要特别赞美一下成立于1790年的当地啤酒厂哈维斯（Harvys）的馅饼和品脱啤酒，就在他们的主场“滴盘”（Dripping Pan），那里是周末游玩的绝佳去处。干得好，洛伊克。
All right. That's pretty darn cool. I know. I'm just getting more and more hungry, too, because now I want pies and pints and I want everything you talked about. Uh-oh. My around the town has food in it. Does it really?
All right. That's pretty darn cool. I know. I'm just getting more and more hungry, too, because now I want pies and pints and I want everything you talked about. Uh-oh. My around the town has food in it. Does it really?|||好的。这真是酷毙了。我知道。我也越来越饿了，因为现在我既想吃馅饼喝啤酒，又想要你刚才聊的所有东西。哦哦。我的“走过大街小巷”里也有吃的。真的吗？
Yes. Page R from Richmond, Virginia said this month, the Richmond Flying Squirrels baseball team will start their 2026 season in their brand new stadium, which was built in the parking lot of the old stadium. Tragic news, however, is that the infamous big dill dog, a hot dog stuffed inside of a whole dill pickle, will not be served at the new stadium. And people are not okay with this. It's me. I'm the people. In unrelated news, I will be purchasing a Costco-sized jar of dill pickles this summer and many hot dogs. They put a hot dog inside a pickle?
Yes. Page R from Richmond, Virginia said this month, the Richmond Flying Squirrels baseball team will start their 2026 season in their brand new stadium, which was built in the parking lot of the old stadium. Tragic news, however, is that the infamous big dill dog, a hot dog stuffed inside of a whole dill pickle, will not be served at the new stadium. And people are not okay with this. It's me. I'm the people. In unrelated news, I will be purchasing a Costco-sized jar of dill pickles this summer and many hot dogs. They put a hot dog inside a pickle?|||是的。来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的佩奇·R（Page R）说，本月，里士满飞松鼠棒球队将在他们全新的体育场开始2026赛季，该体育场建在旧体育场的停车场上。然而，一个悲惨的消息是，那个臭名昭著的“大酸黄瓜热狗”（big dill dog）——一种塞进整根酸黄瓜里的热狗——将不会在新体育场供应。人们对此非常不满。这个人就是我。我就是那些人。在不相关的新闻中，我今年夏天将购买一罐好市多（Costco）大号的酸黄瓜和许多热狗。他们把热狗塞进黄瓜里？
Oh, I would love to try that. Yeah? Yeah. Do you put relish on your hot dogs anyway? I don't, but I love pickles. Because I like my hot dog with mustard and relish, although I did really like the Chicago dog, and they put all kinds of stuff on that. I would try it. Okay.
Oh, I would love to try that. Yeah? Yeah. Do you put relish on your hot dogs anyway? I don't, but I love pickles. Because I like my hot dog with mustard and relish, although I did really like the Chicago dog, and they put all kinds of stuff on that. I would try it. Okay.|||哦，我很想尝尝这个。是吗？对啊。你吃热狗时会加酸黄瓜酱（relish）吗？我不加，但我喜欢酸黄瓜。因为我喜欢热狗配芥末酱和酸黄瓜酱，尽管我也很喜欢芝加哥热狗，上面放了各种各样的东西。我会试试的。好的。
So our next around the town is from our snail mail. I guess that's what we'll call the post office mail. Yes. And I would like to congratulate Becky G. and her husband Matt from Paragold, Arkansas there who sent this in. They were married last year, and Becky sent us a wedding invite with a lovely letter, and I'm going to share some of it now. Becky said, as a police dispatcher for a small agency, I have some long bits of downtime.
So our next around the town is from our snail mail. I guess that's what we'll call the post office mail. Yes. And I would like to congratulate Becky G. and her husband Matt from Paragold, Arkansas there who sent this in. They were married last year, and Becky sent us a wedding invite with a lovely letter, and I'm going to share some of it now. Becky said, as a police dispatcher for a small agency, I have some long bits of downtime.|||所以我们的下一个“走过大街小巷”来自传统信件。我想这就是我们所说的邮政信件吧。是的。我要向来自阿肯色州帕拉古尔德的贝姬·G（Becky G.）和她的丈夫马特（Matt）表示祝贺，他们寄来了这封信。他们去年结婚了，贝姬给我们寄来了一份婚礼请柬和一封可爱的信，我现在要分享其中的一部分。贝姬说：作为一家小型机构的警察调度员，我有一些很长的空闲时间。
That time has awarded me the chance to listen to your podcast multiple times and read through the Office BFF's book. She goes on to say, I've lost count of the number of times I've gone home and I'd recount my day to Matt and end up saying, oh, the ladies said this about that. I was super stoked to discover you ladies doing this podcast and continue to share your life with us. Thank you for that. I know you guys can't possibly make it to our reception, but just know you ladies are with
That time has awarded me the chance to listen to your podcast multiple times and read through the Office BFF's book. She goes on to say, I've lost count of the number of times I've gone home and I'd recount my day to Matt and end up saying, oh, the ladies said this about that. I was super stoked to discover you ladies doing this podcast and continue to share your life with us. Thank you for that. I know you guys can't possibly make it to our reception, but just know you ladies are with|||这段时间给了我多次收听你们的播客并读完《办公室死党》（Office BFFs）这本书的机会。她接着说：我已经记不清有多少次我回到家，向马特复述我的一天，最后说：哦，女士们是这么说的。我很兴奋地发现你们这些女士在做这个播客，并继续与我们分享你们的生活。为此谢谢你们。我知道你们不可能赶来参加我们的招待会，但只要知道你们一直陪伴着
me as I walked down the aisle at our elopement chapel to the mashup of Canon and D and the office theme song. Thank you for being you. Love Becky. Oh, congratulations, Becky and Matt. And you know, lady, we get so many wedding invites. And I think lady and are around the towns, we could have an opportunity every once in a while to give a shout out to a happy couple. I love that. All right. Next up is Demi or Demi S from Homewood, Alabama, who says, hey ladies, over the course of the past few weeks, pink tutus have been popping up on trees. statues and parks and city centers and pretty much anything that can be tutued.
me as I walked down the aisle at our elopement chapel to the mashup of Canon and D and the office theme song. Thank you for being you. Love Becky. Oh, congratulations, Becky and Matt. And you know, lady, we get so many wedding invites. And I think lady and are around the towns, we could have an opportunity every once in a while to give a shout out to a happy couple. I love that. All right. Next up is Demi or Demi S from Homewood, Alabama, who says, hey ladies, over the course of the past few weeks, pink tutus have been popping up on trees. statues and parks and city centers and pretty much anything that can be tutued.|||我，当我走过私奔教堂的过道时，背景音乐是《卡农》（Canon in D）和办公室主题曲的混音版。谢谢你们做自己。爱你们的贝姬。哦，恭喜贝姬和马特。你知道吗，女士，我们收到了好多的婚礼请柬。我觉得女士们在“走过大街小巷”环节中，可以偶尔找个机会向幸福的新人送上祝福。我太喜欢这个主意了。好的。接下来是来自阿拉巴马州霍姆伍德的黛米或黛米·S（Demi S.），她说：嗨，女士们，在过去几周里，粉红色的芭蕾舞裙（tutu）突然出现在树木、雕像、公园、市中心以及几乎所有能穿上芭蕾舞裙的东西上。
No one has figured out who is doing the tutuing. A sneaky nighttime artist, perhaps, but it has certainly brought a lot of joy to Birmingham residents and a smile to my face every time I see a new tutu. We are hoping that their next target is Vulcan, a giant iron statue whose bare butt faces homewood. Oh my goodness.
No one has figured out who is doing the tutuing. A sneaky nighttime artist, perhaps, but it has certainly brought a lot of joy to Birmingham residents and a smile to my face every time I see a new tutu. We are hoping that their next target is Vulcan, a giant iron statue whose bare butt faces homewood. Oh my goodness.|||没有人弄清楚是谁在恶作剧给它们穿芭蕾舞裙。也许是一个鬼鬼祟祟的夜间艺术家，但这确实给伯明翰的居民带来了很多欢乐，每次看到一条新的芭蕾舞裙，我的脸上都会露出微笑。我们希望他们的下一个目标是伏尔铿（Vulcan），那是一尊巨大的铁雕像，它光溜溜的屁股正对着霍姆伍德。哦天哪。
Maybe they think he could use some modesty. Is this a job for mom detectives? Road trip to Alabama. Maybe. All right, and now it's time for our office question of the week. It's from Jasmine D. from Montreal, Canada, and she sent in an audio clip. Hi, office ladies. My question for you is, what do you think Pam and Angela's social medias would look like?
Maybe they think he could use some modesty. Is this a job for mom detectives? Road trip to Alabama. Maybe. All right, and now it's time for our office question of the week. It's from Jasmine D. from Montreal, Canada, and she sent in an audio clip. Hi, office ladies. My question for you is, what do you think Pam and Angela's social medias would look like?|||也许他们觉得他需要一点遮羞布。这是妈妈侦探的任务吗？去阿拉巴马州的公路旅行。也许吧。好了，现在是我们的本周办公室问题时间。这个问题来自加拿大蒙特利尔的茉莉·D（Jasmine D.），她发来了一段音频。嗨，办公室女士们。我给你们的问题是，你们觉得帕姆和安吉拉的社交媒体会是什么样子的？
Do you think they would have social media at all? If they did, what kinds of things would they post about? Would they post often? what kinds of things would show up on their feeds. Thank you for all the great laughs, both on the office, on office ladies, and on all of your other great projects that you've worked on over the years. Thanks.
Do you think they would have social media at all? If they did, what kinds of things would they post about? Would they post often? what kinds of things would show up on their feeds. Thank you for all the great laughs, both on the office, on office ladies, and on all of your other great projects that you've worked on over the years. Thanks.|||你们觉得她们会有社交媒体吗？如果有的话，她们会发些什么内容呢？她们会经常发帖吗？她们的动态里会出现什么样的事情。谢谢你们带来的所有欢笑，无论是在《办公室》剧里、在《办公室女士》播客中，还是在你们多年来参与的所有其他伟大项目中。谢谢。
I loved thinking about that too. It made it so fun to just let the show age up into modern times in my brain. Yes. And I had two very specific immediate thoughts about this. Okay, I had one as well. You go first. I think Pam definitely has a private Instagram. because I think she posts a lot of pictures of her kids,
I loved thinking about that too. It made it so fun to just let the show age up into modern times in my brain. Yes. And I had two very specific immediate thoughts about this. Okay, I had one as well. You go first. I think Pam definitely has a private Instagram. because I think she posts a lot of pictures of her kids,|||我也很喜欢思考这个问题。在脑海中让剧中的角色随着时间步入现代，这实在太有趣了。是的。对此我有两个非常具体、当即想到的想法。好吧，我也有一个。你先说。我觉得帕姆绝对有一个私密的Instagram账号。因为我觉得她会发很多她孩子的照片，
but you have to know her in order for her to give you that access. I just felt like she was that kind of person. But since they're living somewhere other than where I think we presume her mom and dad are living, Jim's family is living, this is how people are going to get access to kind of like their little everyday moments of the kids. So I think there is a private Instagram account with all that stuff on it. But then I think she has a public account for her art. Because I think she's been doing more stuff.
but you have to know her in order for her to give you that access. I just felt like she was that kind of person. But since they're living somewhere other than where I think we presume her mom and dad are living, Jim's family is living, this is how people are going to get access to kind of like their little everyday moments of the kids. So I think there is a private Instagram account with all that stuff on it. But then I think she has a public account for her art. Because I think she's been doing more stuff.|||但你必须认识她，她才会给你开通权限。我就是觉得她是那种人。但既然他们住在别的地方，而不是我们猜测她父母居住的地方，也不是吉姆家人居住的地方，大家就是通过这种方式来了解孩子们日常的点点滴滴。所以我认为有一个包含所有这些内容的私密Instagram账号。但与此同时，我认为她有一个用于展示其艺术作品的公开账号。因为我觉得她一直在创作更多东西。
I think she's been painting more nurseries. I think she's been doing murals. I think she's gotten into the graphic design. I think she kind of learned some stuff. So I really think that's taken off for her. And so she has this way that she gets her artwork out to people. I love that. Okay.
I think she's been painting more nurseries. I think she's been doing murals. I think she's gotten into the graphic design. I think she kind of learned some stuff. So I really think that's taken off for her. And so she has this way that she gets her artwork out to people. I love that. Okay.|||我觉得她画了更多婴儿房。我觉得她一直在画壁画。我觉得她涉足了平面设计。我觉得她学到了一些东西。所以我真的觉得这在她的生活中起飞了。因此她有一种将自己的艺术作品推向大众的渠道。我太喜欢了。好的。
Well, here's what I think. I think Angela Martin runs the social media accounts for Shrewt farms. Oh my gosh, yes, she does. Uh-huh, because they have the bed and breakfast, and who knows what else they, like, harvest and sell for the farm, but I think she runs it. Mm-hmm. And I think privately she has, like, some type of Instagram account, but it's private, but she proudly tells people, I don't have any social media for myself.
Well, here's what I think. I think Angela Martin runs the social media accounts for Shrewt farms. Oh my gosh, yes, she does. Uh-huh, because they have the bed and breakfast, and who knows what else they, like, harvest and sell for the farm, but I think she runs it. Mm-hmm. And I think privately she has, like, some type of Instagram account, but it's private, but she proudly tells people, I don't have any social media for myself.|||嗯，我是这么想的。我觉得安吉拉·马丁负责运营“精明农场”（Shrewt Farms）的社交媒体账号。哦天哪，对，她确实负责。嗯哼，因为他们有加宿早餐旅馆（B&B），谁知道他们还为农场收获和销售什么别的呢，但我觉得是由她来运营的。嗯哼。而且我觉得私底下她有某种Instagram账号，但那是私密的，而她会骄傲地告诉别人：“我本人没有任何社交媒体。”
I only do it for the farm. But then she can, then, you know, secretly just, like, scroll and stuff. What do they call that? There's like the person who has an account, but they never post, but that way they can see stuff. Lurking. Lurking? So she's a lurker. I think she has a private lurky account, but then she has the public Shrewd Farms account
I only do it for the farm. But then she can, then, you know, secretly just, like, scroll and stuff. What do they call that? There's like the person who has an account, but they never post, but that way they can see stuff. Lurking. Lurking? So she's a lurker. I think she has a private lurky account, but then she has the public Shrewd Farms account|||我只为农场做这个。但接着她可以，然后呢，你知道的，偷偷地刷一刷什么的。这叫什么来着？就是那种有账号但从不发帖，但可以通过这种方式看别人东西的人。潜水。潜水？所以她是个潜水者。我觉得她有一个私密的潜水账号，但她同时拥有公开的精明农场账号
that she does all the sort of Shrewd Farms business posting. Does she like respond to negative comments and stuff? No, she doesn't like strangers. She doesn't want to engage with people. But I think she's, you know, she's curious and judgy. I see. or something to just get her going. I see. Okay.
that she does all the sort of Shrewd Farms business posting. Does she like respond to negative comments and stuff? No, she doesn't like strangers. She doesn't want to engage with people. But I think she's, you know, she's curious and judgy. I see. or something to just get her going. I see. Okay.|||用来发布各种精明农场的商业动态。她会回复负面评论之类的吗？不，她不喜欢陌生人。她不想与人互动。但我认为她，你知道的，她很好奇又爱评判。我明白了。或者别的什么能触动她的东西。我明白了。好的。
Yeah. Oh, very fun. So fun. What a great question, Jasmina. Thank you so much. All right, everyone. There you have it. That is our episode this week.
Yeah. Oh, very fun. So fun. What a great question, Jasmina. Thank you so much. All right, everyone. There you have it. That is our episode this week.|||是的。哦，太有趣了。太好玩了。茉莉，真是个好问题。非常感谢。好了，各位。就是这样。这就是我们本周的节目。
Travel Journals. Let us know if you want to hear more journals. And let us know if there's a category you'd like to hear about. Yeah. And next week, we've got a pretty exciting episode for you. We do. We have one of the biggest, the office super-fameral coming back to the podcast.
Travel Journals. Let us know if you want to hear more journals. And let us know if there's a category you'd like to hear about. Yeah. And next week, we've got a pretty exciting episode for you. We do. We have one of the biggest, the office super-fameral coming back to the podcast.|||旅行日记。如果你想听更多日记，请告诉我们。如果有哪个分类你想听，也请告诉我们。好的。下周，我们为你们准备了一期相当精彩的节目。没错。我们迎来了最大牌的嘉宾之一，办公室的超级粉丝将重返播客。
Should we say it together? Yeah. One, two, three. Billy Elish. All right, we'll see you then. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
Should we say it together? Yeah. One, two, three. Billy Elish. All right, we'll see you then. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey|||我们要一起说出来吗？好。一，二，三。比利·艾利什（Billie Eilish）。好的，我们到时候见。再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rupertrypt. by Creed Bratton. Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rupertrypt. by Creed Bratton. Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.|||由詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）演奏的《Rupertrypt》。大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），与Wayfair合作。
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||有没有在网上订购过家具，然后心里犯嘀咕：“万一……会怎样？”比如，万一它不结实怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你本来应该在Wayfair上订购的。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，演绎各种风格，扮靓每个温馨小家。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。